at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
oock well hey everybody what's going on
it's Wednesday yeah and there's Tom with
his hat yeah and you're you're getting
cut off
sir well see you always move it over
that way so I tried to like preempt you
is that what it is I tried to preempt
you because always and now you moved it
back to where I would have had see I see
the center see that see the see the see
the mirror I think you just you just
can't leave it the way I put it and you
always got to move it so wherever I put
it you're going to move it no I put it I
make it straight you do it like the
girly Straight girls have a different
straight than men men can make the [__]
straight girls just kind of have it like
this and then you come in and and change
it all right and make it like crooked
okay hold on one second now I'm going to
do something else watch this yeah see
cuz he can't just he can't leave it
alone he can't leave it
alone that I might even do it again
might even do it again why what do you
want to cut my head off for let see why
you want C it's not cut off yeah it is
the top of it is that looks really bad
here bring it back up just just a me
there it is see he just can't stand it
he can't stand it
he always has to mess with it trying to
get a good shot he's always trying to
mess
with oh my God see everybody piling in
everybody's piling in yep piling in
going to be a good show for this really
fun entertaining show about torture yeah
torture yep yeah this is
uh uh pretty fun I you know what it it's
like I'm fascinated by these kind of
topics but
this kind of [__] in particular like
always kind of depresses me a little bit
because I always think to myself it's
like look at the humans boundless
creativity in thinking of these horrible
horrible devices to inflict the greatest
amount of Agony On another person yeah
I'm like think of all the good we could
have done in the world medieval white
folks were the trip man if we actually
tried to do something helpful rather
than this crap yeah uh but uh would do
[__] like this down in meso America you
know the Aztecs and all the other Maya
type people but they always had like a
religious explanation for what they were
doing well they did hear too but I think
most of the time it was most just just
as big as [__] as [__] painful as
possible and warn all the other people
to obey really that that's really what
it was make an example out of people who
didn't obey and I feel like that didn't
even really work no they were psychos
all of
them [__] there's Jen read a book and
she read it to me
um and it was called the better angels
of our nature it talked about stepen
Pinker yeah it talked about the
psychology of the of the
medievals they're [__] nuts man you
you would call them high functioning
Psychopaths by today's standards I
believe
psychos crazy [__] I well and it's
possible that I
mean even even people that had a lot of
money back then I mean think about the
living conditions yeah um and espe es
like if you were a peasant or something
like that it just must have been
horrible
horrible life was just a horrible SLO
you very low standards in things well I
mean it's like it's not like they knew
any better it's just like gee I sure
wish it was 500 years from now and we
could have the internet you know what I
mean it's like nobody was thinking that
but it's just kind of like I can't
imagine that that that people were
really having all that fun of a Time the
the advice the advice that like books
were giving medieval people on how to
how to behave was just [__]
astounding it was [__] like when you're
walking down street with your friends
don't pick up the dead things in the
roads and ask them to smell it don't do
that so they were doing that which is
like some [__] they would do on jackass
yeah yeah
exactly why but they had to tell like
regular people not to do that yeah while
you're at the table don't take a dump or
fart they would was remember that they
said like yeah don't do that at the
table okay [__] [__] nuts man now
I do kind of feel like my dad had to be
told that yeah like not taking dump but
farting you know what I mean yeah I feel
like that's a very dad thing to do like
fart at the table you know what I mean
there was all kinds of weird
[__] evidently they would two friends
would be walking down the street and
just without any warning one of them
would just punch the other one so hard
it just knock teeth out and they'd both
get up laughing like it was funny that
was the [__] medevals did they that book
magic they had a they had a real
different sense of humor back then yeah
you
know m people and and the and the person
who got named would
laugh it's weird yeah it's crazy [__]
like every like it seems like everybody
was like a serial killer yeah some world
[__] of serial killers k a [__] uh
a a world of [__] uh what do you call
them sedom masochistic [__] serial
killers yeah yeah cuz some of the [__]
some of the [__] that they thought of
back then um I don't even think like
some serial Killers nowadays would have
thought of it yeah so it's like the fact
that somebody invented that [__] back
then was just kind of like that sort of
blows my mind a little bit it and they
would do [__] to people that they knew
were innocent yeah of course they knew
they were innocent they' do some [__]
most of the time I just think they
didn't really give a crap just think but
because that's the thing it's like yeah
they justification for it I guess and
you know it's kind of hard to say just
like what one justification was because
there's so many countries did it like
over so many centuries or whatever but
it's just kind of like they're like oh
well we have to um make the punishments
really egregious like really horrible
and public so that'll deter other people
from doing it which like I said didn't
even really work well there wasn't any
law enforcement it was hard to no
investigative ability well and then the
thing too was that then they would do it
to people that like for [__] that
nowadays isn't even illegal yeah like
just you know that some little kid would
like steal a piece of bread or something
they're like well into the thumb screws
for you kid you know what I mean that
kind of [__] I think that's why a lot of
European countries don't have the death
penalty because they associate it with
those times yeah America doesn't I get
it yeah America doesn't really associate
it with that [__] like I said it it
didn't deter [__] obviously America had
a death penalty before there was even
even the United States uh it was
Frontier Justice it made sense if you
stole a horse you hung that person if if
you found him because stealing
somebody's horse was a was murder
essentially yeah yeah uh so stealing was
murder basically because if you stole
any anything from anybody in the in the
old west they wouldn't survive they were
at it was Frontier living and American
morality really started to be built on
that and it still kind of stands today
in most parts of the United States
because most of the United States is not
Urban most of it's suburban and Rural
and it's still kind of like that like
here in Florida you got constitutional
carry everyone can carry weapons but
they have to be
concealed they can't be out in the open
they got to be concealed which you Most
states it's the opposite you can carry
something openly but you can't carry
anything could steal without a permit
here you don't need a permit you just
carry now it doesn't mean you can kill
somebody you got to have
reason but it's like it's like the old
west same thing actually more liberal
than the old west when it comes to guns
like in the old west when you came into
town you usually had to give your guns
up it'd give them to the local police
department the sheriff here you can well
you're not really supposed to
to but uh I don't want to name any bars
you know what bar I'm talking about
those dudes are carrying guns in
there yeah yeah and everybody knows Zach
says my vote already and mine is too I'm
going to tell you right now is uh is on
the thing that they use in the
Inquisition that get stuck up your ass
and spread out yeah thing murder Hornet
the pair of Ang pair of Anguish yes
remember that's one of the ones I was
going to talk about yeah it wasn't just
a torture man [__] from the Medieval
era suck it up they they suck it up
girls badges too yeah like women's
badges too another or in your mouth wow
yeah break your teeth too wonder if they
did it till it broke
bones wonder how far they did it well it
did Kill Some people I'm pretty kill
okay the uh another excuse me
hiccuping another thing that uh was was
a trip about the medievals was their
forms of
Justice you had trial by combat trial by
ordeal and another one was is like to St
to uh married couples that
were divorcing or had some kind of a
disagreement between the two could
challenge each other to basically to a
duel to the death that was awesome are
you going to challenge me to a duel yeah
yeah that was like they were trying to
reach some kind of a settlement and what
they how they would do it was funny
they'd put the dude in a hole that went
up to about his shoulders he couldn't
get out of the hole and uh he only had
like a
I think he had a knife and then the
woman could be above the hole and and
she had a shield I think was sharp so
like handicapping was what they so yeah
they would handicap it was kind of I
think they learned that from the Romans
because the Roman gladiator fights were
like that their sense of fair was kind
of weird like yeah the guy was heavily
armored but he can't see anything in
that helmet that kind of deal you know
and he's fighting against a guy who
doesn't have any armor but he's real
fast and has a spear that kind of [__]
but that's that's the way that's the way
they would do it yeah it evidently like
[__] they'd fight each other to the
death it seems a little extreme I mean
maybe you should just go to couples
counseling and just like work it out I
think a lot of that was I think I think
a lot of that was psych psychological
they didn't want people [__]
challenging each other so they made the
challenges [__] basically to the
death real real D they tried to keep
people to keep everything it was a way
to keeping people in line in other words
like you know it's it's like don't
complain unless you're willing to go
through the just jce system you know I
think that's had although like I said
it's like I can see why they were
thinking that but it's just like in
practice it never worked out like like I
said it's no matter how horrific the
torture that they would do like in
saying we're making examples of people
it's like you're never going to stop
crime just you're just not going no
they'll invent it if they can't find it
that's another thing right they'll just
invent the crime they'll just accuse
people of doing something and they
didn't do it that kind of [__] well yeah
that there was a Hu there there was a
huge indust see the entire witch trial
yeah there was a huge industry around
around this you know whenever they would
do trials or tortures executions it was
a [__] big deal it was a huge
Festival man they everybody they love
that [__] they bring their children and
[__] picnic lunch and everything
woohoo we're going to go see the torture
today they're selling food going to
[__] Disney World food and
refreshments and [__] it was a carnival
yeah they just thought it was hilarious
yeah they loved it they loved it weirdo
and like you see and really this went on
for a long time it humans I don't think
really changed that much over over time
the situation has changed but humans
themselves I don't think I think they're
still like this um like even in the
1700s you know you in France you'd have
revolutionary courts beheading [__]
royalty and the Army standing right
there not knowing really what to do
they're just in formation yeah I guess
this is what's happening this is what
we're doing today we're beheading the
King today okay you know and you know
they they would just behead anybody who
anybody who was accused they put before
a revolutionary court and it wasn't the
real Court it was just some guys you
know some guys some Rabel rousers they'
sentenced the dude to death and then
most of it was [__] robes Pierre then
he ended up getting beheaded himself
later on because revolution's always
become a [__] circular firing
squad say the wrong thing and all of a
sudden you get accused or really just
another person enters the scene who
wants your position will accuse you and
if you can't talk your way out of it you
get executed as a [__] traitor
to the Revolution and when you look at a
lot of the Revolution [__] it looked a
lot
medieval and there's a long time in
between these two periods we're talking
about but
it humans remain them same
[__] genx Jason says oops I got way
behind on my on the comment God damn it
I'm getting all these notifications uh
genx Jason says where did it go uh did I
miss the pre-show fight over the camera
angle yes you did yeah um it's back
there we're so predictable yeah well
because he doesn't come in early like he
came in earlier and I was like does the
lighting look okay and he said yeah but
he didn't say anything about the camera
angle but then like when he sat down and
like the show started he's like oh it's
all [__] up and like he's started
messing with yeah she cut herself off no
you cut your no you cut me okay I look
we're having a replay of this [__]
[__] you can go back and watch it we
settled that one no you cut the top of
my head I said no you cut the side your
arm off no it's not cuz that's not your
no before that's what I fixed see she
wants to fight I'm not fighting all
right um Zach says do you think people
were just legit less intelligent
generally back then or have we just
always been a certain level of smart
yeah about the same um I think we've
been about the same but I don't know if
it's so much intelligence as it's just
cultural situ and the it's situational
rather than intelligence-based if that
makes any sense and it's like easy to be
that way when everyone else is that way
you can you can go back and read roman
writings translated into English like
you can read suetonius or [__] you
know [__] you can go back and even
look read Cicero it was like that [__]
was written today yeah it seems very it
yeah and they were just talking about
political corruption and how [__]
governments are nonfunctional and how
they [__] all end up becoming real
corrupt and start declining and that
your ruling class are actually a bunch
of selfish losers that don't care about
the [__] Republic the people and they
start insourcing all the [__] labor
to slaves and [__] anything that
[__] up the economy makes them wealthy
that's what happens is it's part of a
[__] cycle you know and you see it
happening today in the west you know
while the other parts of the world are
rising it's always rising and
declining even Frederick nii says that
you know or n whatever you want to call
him um that the spirit of the tiger
travels around the earth it goes through
different peoples you know what I mean
and he called called them you know uh
the the master cultures Mis usually
mated into Master race but he said that
the Japanese were like that for a Time
the French were like that for a Time the
Chinese it just travels through there's
always going to be kind of like a a key
master culture that's [__] having all
the Innovations and doing all the
[__] good [__] while everybody else
is kind of floundering it's because
everybody's on a different
Cycles murder Hornet said BTK would love
to live back then yeah probably he'd fit
right in
uh Mr 88 said does anyone find it less
than ironic that extreme torture found
footing with the rise of church
influence uh yeah the problem is it's
like I don't think it necessarily takes
religious belief to be into this kind of
[__] everywhere um it yeah it happens
everywhere however I will say that um
usually having that type of religious
belief and having everybody kind of
going along with it is always like
really dangerous because then you have
like essentially like Supernatural
justification well God said it was okay
and so and we have the power of God so
we can do whatever the [__] we want to
which is always a really dangerous prop
yeah but you can do the same thing with
politics well I know that maoism and
certain forms of Marxism in a way that's
kind it's kind of the same it's the same
thing BEC I can explain it all it's all
the same idea there's no difference
between politics and religion it's it's
it it's it's it's a [__] what do you
call it it's a
spectrum it goes from Legends
into [__]
mythology into religion into
psychology excuse me into philosophy
into psychology and then in in then into
politics it's all the same kind of
spectrum it's a spectrum of different
levels of belief and
rationality the Communists were doing
the same kinds of tortures or even worse
because you're a traitor to the people
or because you're you know what I mean
you're you're part of the three olds
that kind of thing you you can justify
anything as long as you believe in
something ideologies are very dangerous
all of them well anytime anyone thinks
that they have all the answers wherever
they got these answers from yep that's
always it's it's always better to I
always think it's always better to doubt
yeah ideologies are human constructs and
humans aren't very good at constructing
always always always like whatever it is
that you think you know please please
please always keep open the possibility
that you could be totally totally wrong
about that yeah that you're totally
wrong I think you'll be okay because
assume that you've been lied to because
you have well basically lied assume that
you've been that you're wrong about
things assume you know what I mean like
just never ever ever think that you are
100% sure of anything you know what I
mean cuz you're probably not unless and
and the second that you start having
that mindset then that's when [__] gets
starts to get bad yeah if you think
you're right and everybody else is wrong
or you think you're on the winning side
or God is on your side or [__] you're
on the right side of his history then
that what that means is you're going to
make a lot of enemies and your ideology
is going to tell you you're going to
have to defeat these enemies somehow up
to and including killing
them that's that's the cycle all these
big Mass murderers all had
ideologies you know mustache man in the
B cross [__] the Romans had
ideologies they went out and just
[__] tore tore up Germania it was
Caesar's war against Germany or G
Germania is what they called it was was
basically ethnic cleansing it was just
they just wiped them out because they
believed they were civilized he just
Savages you can do what you want with
them you know well that's another thing
uh the second that you start othering or
dehumanizing other human beings then
you're also you're heading down that
path people are going to have a bad time
yeah um Zach said talking about the pair
of Anguish which like I said I'll get
into bit uh it says then again based off
the porn I've seen I can think of at
least a few German dudes who would
absolutely love that thing you know what
I mean it's like well I have a picture
of it cuz I do actually have pictures of
some of the stuff cuz it was easier for
me to see how they worked like when I
had photos of them so I do have them so
I have a picture of it and I was just
kind of like if that wasn't quite so
spiky um I can see people being kind of
into that and another thing too is that
it kind of looks like well it doesn't
it's a similar in design to like a a
speculum like if you go when you go to
the gynecologist it's the same kind of
thing where they stick it up your cooch
and like spreading it out like that but
this is like a million times worse yeah
you know what I mean yeah and those
people back then they they they weren't
practiced all that kind of [__] I mean
nowadays some of these girls in porn you
know they [__] they could take
anything but you know they practiced
yeah they anal Queens they can [__]
take a coffee can you know or like that
girl that can stick her entire arm up
her ass like up to her elbow up to her
elbow it's pretty impressive that's not
that impressive because that's not very
big around well I know but what was
impressive was that girl we were looking
at that put it was that [__] was [__]
huge that was about the size of a fire
extinguisher that rubber thing yeah
that's right yeah yeah it was flat on
the end
yeah we were studying that girl's work
she was a master she was a masterpiece
hey everybody's good at the F said damn
you got to work up to that [__] yeah so
Oscar says Jen VHS 85 just came out a
couple days ago yeah um would love a
review I will eventually do a review of
that matter of fact um Tom was at bike
night last night and I was like oh yeah
VHS 85 like uh just came on shutter so I
went to watch it but shutter wasn't
working so I went over to Amazon Prime
and watch watch Renfield instead but I
um but I definitely will do a review of
that because I know I did all the other
VHS movies and I did actually want to
see this one out they were working on
the internet last night well that's why
yeah it just went off at like 10:30 or
something like that went off for a few
hours yeah and then I was just kind of
like oh well I was trying to watch
something but it just kind of you
know um but yeah so let's see now I got
way behind on the comments but yeah so
here's the thing like I know that cuz
what you were saying before not on this
show but I think you said it on Monday's
show when I said what the topic for this
show was and you were saying oh they
should bring some of that [__] back and
everything like that I will admit some
of these
tortures um if you did it to somebody
like Ted Bundy or something like that
I'm not going to feel too bad about it
all right I don't think it should be
done you know just ever um but like I
said if somebody took somebody like Ted
Bundy and did that to him I'm not going
cry about it you know what I mean but
then on the other hand I was thinking to
myself well what would be the point of
that though you know it's like one it's
not going to deter other serial killers
cuz serial killer is going to serial
kill um you know they're just going to
do it anyway and it's not like Ted Bundy
hypothetically is going to suddenly
realize that he's a terrible person and
is going to like stop doing that [__]
that's not going to happen either so I
think like really the only we're just
giving ourselves
like a sick satisfaction watching this
[__] suffer the way he made
other people suffer like I said I don't
know if there's really any point of it
beyond that you know what I'm saying
although I would I would admit that you
know that's really the only kind of
person I could see justify like doing it
to but then again I don't really see any
point to it on the other hand so Mr ID
got about who would Jesus bomb and there
was no Jesus well yeah we know yeah
there was no Jesus I used to think there
was was a historical Jesus that a
religion was based around an old
preacher or something down in Judea and
the Romans no it was an artificial
construct there was never a
Jesus everything we have about him was
borrowed from another religion every
quote is kind of borrowed from other
religions or inspired by Socrates and
[__] like that it's just a Roman god
that's all it
is genx Jason said have I done a review
of the Steven Pinker book I haven't I
don't usually do reviews of um of um
non-fiction but I don't know I might one
of these days I'd have to like reread it
because it was several years ago and I
forgot like a lot of the stuff that it
was in there but it was actually really
good that's not the only book of his
that I've read but um but yeah it was
really interesting and I think that was
the most interesting aspect of it just
the different um mindsets and the
different cultural context between uh
people back then like what was
acceptable back then and what is
acceptable nowadays you know what I mean
uh but yeah so
let's oh God Danny rolling with all
these dad jokes Mr T used to wrap his
enemies in flatbread to torture them
because he liked to pee to the
fool that was pretty good that was a
pretty good one that was a pretty good
one but yeah some of these um I did see
a video I think it was on YouTube I
didn't watch the whole thing but I just
saw like the little teaser or whatever
where people were trying out the torture
like not until they died or had their
limbs ripped off or anything like that
but I think it was some of the ones that
were less fatal just to like just a
little bit like to see what it would be
like and I was kind of wondering too I
was watching bayy seran did a really
funny like hourong uh dark history
episode about medieval torture methods
and she actually asked a really good
question at the end she's like if you
had to be subjected to any of these
torture methods like which one would you
pick and it was kind and I was like none
I well yeah they were all pretty bad but
well that's kind of the whole thing is
you're supposed to choose the one that's
like the least bad the rack
probably yeah yeah maybe everything else
is [__] I mean they're still pulling
you apart yeah it's a lot better than
putting your foot in that iron shoe and
have pour [__] boiling oil in it or
boil boil your [__] molten lead you
know pouring that down your throat and
[__] like that holy crap like I said how
why would you even think of that yeah
the fact that people just thought of
that back then and like did it like it
was no thing is just that blows my
[__] mind you know what I mean they
were [__] psychos that's yeah that's
what I mean it's just like I really I
don't think they were necessarily any
dumber than we are no they liked it but
they for sure were and and I'm not
saying like people nowadays like we like
morbid [__] like you know I like stuff
like that but I don't want to really see
the [__] I don't want that to happen to
a real person like I'll watch horror
movies all day long but that's fake you
still got Hamas throwing people off
buildings and [__] well I know that and
I'm not saying I'm not saying that I'm
just
it's there they were regular people it's
just they were in a much harsher
environment yeah that was probably a big
factor people were a lot worse I think
that's another thing um they weren't
doing this to Modern people that were
raised in a civilized culture with ideas
of like law or morality they didn't
really have that the closest thing they
had to morality was probably religion
and a lot a lot of the [__] that
religion taught them at that time was
kind of [__] backwards yeah and their
interpretations of what religion was
supposed to be was kind of [__] up it
wasn't what I don't think was originally
supposed to be when it and when it came
out in the Roman period they had kind of
perverted it with their own bad
character because it was Christianity
was just part of the Roman State when it
and it was a product of the Roman state
it didn't come from the people that's
that's all myth um true Bible
historians uh have have gone through
it guys like carrier and [__] um [__]
we had him on the show what was his name
uh Robert Price Robert Price Dr Robert
Price they'll tell you that it was
totally a product of the Roman
government by the time it Rome Rome
broke apart in a bunch of pieces and
then you had kingdoms and and monarchs
basically they were kind of like
cartels you know they weren't
respectable or anything they were just
gangs and they' enslaved people made
them work surfs and [__] had them tied
to the
land uh there was Merchant stuff going
on now there was certain parts of the
Medieval era was supposed to be real
nice I think it was like the late
medieval period supposed be pretty good
um then it turned into the Renaissance
but a lot of that early [__] was pretty
bad and of course there was always these
weird abuses and you you might have [__]
like this going on these weird tortures
going on in one area but then in another
area is in another kingdom you know it
was okay it depending on where you were
at what time wasn't uniform they didn't
have like telecommunication or mass
media if you if your local area was okay
you probably thought everything was all
right because you didn't know what was
going on in other places right yeah you
could just have a nice life some yeah I
think they're regular people just
that if you look at their art you you
know if you have any training in art how
artst they didn't understand perspective
to well everything looked real wooden
and lifeless whoever was making that art
was not a real artist it was just like a
worker but what's funny is that they put
that art in pretty good nice places it
tells me that
they they didn't have real highly uh
artistic or developed brains they're
real real
materialistic kind of like a sign
of good way to put it is like they were
real ghetto oh be well I've also heard
I've also heard arguments that a lot of
uh art of the Middle Ages particular
Early Middle Ages well I actually like I
actually like that kind of flat stylized
style that that a lot of them did um was
because it was almost seen as
um uh maybe sacriligious or something
like that to make um human figures that
looked too real yeah you know what I
mean that's an excuse
no I'm just saying i' I've heard that
that that uh they might have said that
brought they might have said that but
the reason why they were saying that is
because they were still examples of
Roman statuary and art floating around
the Medieval World and they were looking
at that it's medieval [__] is plainly
inferior to Roman art the Romans were
much better especially in
sculpture so they had to explain it
somehow oh well they weren't Christians
we're Christians we don't you know we
don't want to insult God those naked
dudes yeah and we don't want to insult
God by trying to like imitate his
Perfections you know that's that kind
that's what they're going to try to
rationalize it that way no they just
couldn't draw [__] couldn't draw they
couldn't draw they couldn't [__] they
couldn't
sculpt you know the rumans were great
man they could [__] sculpt a a person
and just it would just look like a
photograph you know we have examples of
[__] that they dug up out old theaters
busts and stuff and it looks like a
photograph of that that dude that's how
that dude looked they knew exactly what
they were doing cuz they can see where
things were repaired where they knocked
off a little bit of the nose and then
they [__] had to fix it go back there
and recar that
nose they could get the joints to be
perfect so you would you would you
wouldn't notice it all [__] look classy
sitting there you know and in stone
white and everything look like a [__]
Joy Division album cover but if you were
to see it in real life it would look
like some kind of pers and disc disco
Tech all that [__] was painted would
have looked crappy as [__] probably
although I don't know maybe they maybe
they had good paint technology maybe it
looked like a tempura or something maybe
it looked real life life like but this
[__] was outside so I don't think it
could have a lot of it was outside on
top of buildings so I don't think that
paint could have been real
lifelike and and to stand up to the
weathering in the sun they probably
[__] slap paint on it every year Mr
88 said uh not medieval but being drawn
in quartered sounds Beyond awful you
would feel it all yeah that um that
would suck a lot
uh there was a lot of different methods
for doing it but I think most people
nowadays associate it with the with the
horses like pulling your limbs up and
[__] like that but yeah that's pretty
[__] up uh Victor says the Brazen Bowl
had to be the worst yeah
cfuck yeah I've got that in here too
actually uh when I was in yeah when I
was in St Augustine they have a a
surprisingly good medieval Torture
Museum in there which um it's crazy
because you go in and there's just like
a little gift shop in the front and
there's like a little sign saying like
you know pay however much it is like to
go into the and I was just thinking it
was just going to be like one room or
two rooms but it's massive it's like I
didn't realize it was that big back
there but it was just like it's it's
really cool actually so if you're ever
in s Augustine like it it doesn't look
like anything from the outside but go in
there because it's like it's really
really cool and it's all dark and spooky
and it's got [__] uh the sound
effects like it like screaming and [__]
like that like quietly in the background
it's pretty [__] up uh Mr 88 also says
hard 2D medieval art is my favorite art
style uh does anyone know if that style
has a specific name I feel like it does
and it's it Baro no that that's some
Spanish that's later yeah later um it
does but I can't think of it right I
took many many art history classes in uh
college but I can't remember the terms
for everything yeah so um but I I like
it a lot too like um when I go when I
went to um the met in New York City they
have a massive like um medieval section
and they have like all this like
gorgeous like stained glass windows and
like all this kind of stuff and I love
all that kind of stuff they did end up
making good Cathedrals and [__] yeah
yeah yeah flying buttresses going and
gargoyles on them but that was later
yeah was later they got good at their
[__] but they never quite matched the
Romans when it came to
sculpting they didn't couldn't make a
real lifelike
sculpture well no I guess some of that
that was Renaissance though by the
Renaissance they could yeah yeah yeah
Sarah also brought up the pair of
Anguish oh yeah we're going to talk
about that um yeah we kind of discussed
that one how some people might some some
people in porn might be into that uh
dannyel Rowling said Master Fran Schmidt
who was a 15th century German
executioner and wrote in Daily diary
about what it's like to be an
executioner he definitely would make for
a decent show and he got executed so
yeah I yeah I'm G have to write that
down France Schmidt okay uh Victor said
yeah I was at the last week it was cool
yeah that was one of my favorite um
sections of the Met is all of the
medieval it's a it's a huge huge wing of
all the medieval art to make a real
fluid drawing or sculpture both
hemispheres of the brain have to be
working correctly and they have to be
working in unison so it just flows it
gives a
Galt and you kind of go into a trance
when you do it you you when you at the
end of the work day whatever you kind of
forgot how you did the [__] before and
it'll take you a while to get back in
into the the groove kind of like kind of
reminds me that Star Trek episode where
McCoy got the alien knowledge he was
putting Spock's brain back in you know
what I mean he get halfway in he goes
how was I doing this there's too many NS
how was that well I just I'll just keep
going that's kind of what it is what
it's like to uh to draw something if
you're doing it correctly and it'll look
lifelike when you get done the medievals
couldn't do
that the Romans could though
yeah it just tells me that the Romans
were a lot more had a lot more developed
Minds on average at least their artists
and their work people had a lot more
developed minds they had artists they
had Superstar artists the
Romans so uh their name's lost to
history but they could tell that these
are the same sculptors doing some of
this
[__] although now that I'm thinking
about it I mean well I was going to say
Leonardo da Vinci but he was a little
past that's early Renaissance that's
early Renaissance because I've seen some
of his paintings like in person MH and
and that was the new beginning yeah and
the thing about it is that you know it's
it's easy to be like oh wow they're
beautiful like when you just see a
picture of them but when you see them in
real life they
look three-dimensional like they look
like you could reach into them yeah you
know what I mean for those of you who
didn't take history courses Renaissance
means rebirth what's being reborn is the
knowledge of the Roman Empire or the
Roman Republic after the stupid Middle
Ages yeah although that's a that is also
simplification that's a stereotype there
was a lot of [__] advancements in mid
Ages were especially weaponry and
Metallurgy they and torture devices yeah
they they did were they were good at
creative especially in certain areas you
know some of their technology was better
than Roman technology but their
literature wasn't that good their art
wasn't that good but it came back later
Renaissance then when Renaissance
happened they started kicking ass Europe
started to slowly like become a power in
the world and that's what started the
discovery of the new world and the
expansion of the of the of the European
type civilizations it went out
throughout the world because of the
Renaissance yep which is funny we
weren't the only people that did that
China had that [__] too but they were
insular they didn't
leave um jangha [__] he was had a
huge [__]
Fleet super ships I think one of them
might have even been a steam ship it had
horses in and everything this is in the
Middle Ages it went to Europe it made it
to Europe they saw it they saw Africa
and then they went back to China
reported what they saw and they had a
new emperor when they got back and told
them to burn all those ships and never
go never leave again they didn't crazy
that is crazy crazy yeah Jean ha was a
unic well and I mean the thing about
Europe was that it was very I mean there
was so much trading and [__] going on
that they had so much influence like
from other parts of the world yeah but
there's a lot of which really helped out
the West doesn't understand China
the med medieval during our medieval
period the Chinese were [__] way
Advanced they had all kinds of cool
[__] they were dealing with steam
engines and
[__] steam boats it's amazing they were
way ahead but they didn't project
it well maybe they were afraid everybody
was going to like take their [__] uh it
was a bunch of Waring kingdoms and it
was they were they had a pretty big
piece of land there were no reason for
them to go anywhere yeah they stayed
there fighting each
other good job
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah um one of the things that
I was reading about torture which always
kind of made me laugh I was always just
kind of like well you know particularly
like when we did the show about the
witch trials and everything like that I
said to some degree they had to know
that people would confess to anything if
you put them through enough pain right
and I think on some level they did know
that because I think in a lot of
jurisdictions they did have a law that
said well if you confess to something
under torture you also had to confess to
it later like when you weren't being
tortured so they could say it was legit
yeah which which meant that they'
torture you again right that's what I
just said that's what I was going to say
I was like but the only caveat to that
is that if you were like no I didn't
mean any of that then like well let's
put you back on the rack until you say
what we want check so I was like so
what's the [__] point of that you
know what I mean it's honestly the I I
don't really see any point of at all
it's like look if you just want to
torture them just to get your rocks off
then they're just going to do it it's
like if if you're not going to accept
the confession if you're going to kill
them anyway it's like why do they even
have to say anything
my I studied this period throughout my
life there was and I remember seeing
that there was a lot of
evidence that there were Medieval people
that knew that this was all [__]
well there has kind offf because it
wasn't the same everywhere at all times
right they'd have some guys doing this
[__] up [__] and uh 40 miles away
there's some other people going what
those what are they [__] doing they
crazy are you guys nuts yeah all right
so you can't paint them all with the
same brush I think certain areas were
real bad probably big cities bigger
areas with higher population density
probably you didn't want to be there you
probably better off out in the country
somewhere living on a Manor from some
local Lord that was a good like a good
Lord or a good King you know right
somebody who [__] knew that is they
were [__] crazy a [__] lunatic
yeah right yeah right which yeah well
that's what I mean it's like we do kind
of have a perception of Middle Ages you
know you immediately conjures up
Dungeons and torture devices but
obviously it wasn't like that everywhere
but you still couldn't you still
couldn't pay me to go [__] back then
in a time machine if I had one no
[__] way I'd get burned on burned at
the steak within five [__] minutes
yeah
hygiene hygiene would be pretty bad
probably yeah it's like you probably
[__] you die of some horrible disease
like the second you got there they would
have never believed that we were in our
50s that's true cuz we have all our
teeth yeah and [__] you know person
at 50 was [__] trashed and I feel
like most people nowadays like yeah have
all of their teeth yeah in in their 50s
which was not a thing that would have
happened back then they' trip out over
your implants they probably yeah like
what how how'd you do that yeah then
they'd be like burner at the steak
I think that's also a kind of
a I think that's also I don't think they
would do that they would just you could
say I was in a far away land you could
do this in a far away land they you know
the doctors did it they were oh wow you
can you can you do it you you know I
want my wife to have some of those that
kind of [__] you know it's probably what
they would do I think they were just nor
people right just didn't want to get
wrapped up in any of their [__]
Justice systems that's the problem kind
of keep your head down yeah yeah and I
think that might have been the idea to
keep your head down well yeah I'm sure
that's what most people were doing yeah
cuz the rulers knew I'm sure they knew
that that was [__] the idea was just
to hold the people in Terror that's how
you controlled them yeah and so you had
these systems to scare the [__] out of
them which like I said what not what poy
oh yeah which you probably had to in
some areas because they were probably
pretty [__] unruly compared to what
what we what I read about them they were
kind of savages although like I said I
don't really think that any of this
really deterred any of that it still
took place hard to deter a Savage that's
what I'm saying so it's like there
wasn't really you're probably dealing
with people that had
about you're probably dealing with like
65 70 IQ dumb most of
them Zack says it would be hilarious to
take a figure from history and take them
to bring them to modern day Henry VI is
my
choice I've often thought about that
like who if I could go back in time and
bring one person like to the modern era
who would it be would it would I want to
bring somebody that would it would like
just totally blow their minds and they
would freak out or would I want to bring
somebody that I thought might get it you
know what I mean I'd like to bring
[__] guys Julius Caesar back you
think yeah because he was intelligent
enough to know what was going on he
probably yeah yeah he instantly adapt I
want him to write a whole book he wrote
a book but I think a lot of his
propaganda yeah about what he did in
Germany or what they used to call
Germany I would be kind of curious like
you wrote like a military man sounded
like the 20th century yeah sounded like
something somebody like that I kind of
feel like a philosopher or a scientist
would probably be a lot more would
probably get it a lot more like even if
[__] would freak him out and stuff
because it probably would but they if
you explained it to them they would
understand it reading Julius and reading
Patton are similar yeah you know and
there's a lot of time in between 2,000
years between them guys but real similar
yeah they would have liked each other
Patton was Patton believed that he had
been reincarnated that he had fought in
[__] Greek he fought with [__] he
fought under he served under um uh was
his name um Greek guy he went went to
India
[__]
Alexander he thought he worked he was
one of Alexander's [__] men I don't I
don't know if it's true I mean I don't
know you know I don't hey I don't
believe in reincarnation reincarnation
might be a possibility based on some of
my [__] near-death experiences I
don't know if he remembered it but I
think he was into the occult P love the
occult cuz any anybody that says they
were reincarnated nobody's ever just
says they were reincarnated it's just
some like random Schmo you know what I
mean it was well he said he was he was
like somebody that was kind of cool or
famous he said no he didn't say he was
famous he said he was in Alexander's
Army well still that's still still kind
of like that's that's adjacent to a
famous person it's not like you were
just some random peasant out in the
middle of he said all he said he was a
soldier in all of his
lives okay that's what he said I mean
hey generals back in those days [__]
liked they like to play games on damn
sand tables yeah yeah and they were kind
of like larpers and they were role
players they you know they were the
original Gamers yeah generals were
Gamers back Dungeons and Dragons yeah
exactly that was before operations took
over during World War
II yeah that was the old school generals
Artisan generals
yeah so you want to talk about some
[__] up let's go ahead and go torture
devices okay they're ready we I mean you
know these are just kind of all over the
place some of the ones that like that we
were going to talk about like some
people have already brought up but um
but yeah these are like not really in
any particular order they were just kind
of the order that I stuck them in here
so I think you mentioned this one before
maybe not by name but uh yeah you had
the boot now there was a lot of
different versions of this one um one of
the early versions I believe was
actually not so much an actual boot as
they would just kind of take these um
like four pieces of wood like almost
like little 2x4s or something like that
and then they would kind of like nail it
together like around your leg like
around your uh Shin or your calf or
whatever and then they would Hammer
wedges like in between the boards which
would like kind of Squish your leg and
then they just kept putting more wedges
in there until you blacked out or until
you confessed to whatever now the more
famous version of that which I think I
have a picture of uh was called the
Spanish boot so we got pictures and I
think I have a picture of it where is it
at oh maybe I don't okay never
mind maybe I don't I don't what is it
titled uh yeah I titled everything maybe
I forgot that one oh yeah well you can
imagine I don't have a picture of that
one okay okay I thought I did but I
guess I lost it um but yeah the Spanish
boot was actually made of iron and that
actually did kind of look like a boot
and the same kind of thing they would
take like wood or iron wedges and then
like Hammer them in between where the
iron was and your skin you know what I
mean yeah they also had one that was
called a shin Crusher and that was like
two curved iron plates that had like all
of these like teeth and like metal kn
and [__] like that in there and that was
just like to break your leg your shin
bone like pretty much uh they also had
one that was called a foot press and
this was two horizontal iron plates and
it had a like a crank or a screw on it
and they would just like Crank it like
to break all the bones in your foot um
the now in some variations like the
bottom plate had kind of like little
ribs on it so when your foot started
like bleeding or sweating or whatever
like your foot wouldn't slip out of it
but they also had one in Germany cuz of
course it was um that had an upper plate
on it that had a bunch of spikes in it
just to make it like even super pain
more painful like you know what I mean
not just breaking all the bones in your
foot but also putting a bunch of holes
in your feet too so that's
nice um also and I never heard of this
one this was called combing or cing now
you know back when um and I guess I
don't I don't know what they use
nowadays but you know like um those
weird Combs that they use like for wool
like before they put it through the um
through the spindle you know what I mean
they would take those like these metal
Combs and then they would just like lay
you down and tie you up and then they
would just comb it like all over your
[__] skin and basically just like Fay
your skin off what was it again it was
called combing or it's it's like a you
know like a wool comb they would you
have those wool comb things they would
just take off a bit of [__] and they
would just like take off off you off of
you yes well would not it would go
through the skin and then eventually go
into the meat yeah yeah yeah which I
can't yeah it was just like yeah I I
can't [__] imagine that that's only
[__] comes up with this cut that's
what I mean and that's and that was like
that one I feel like that one they
didn't even have to invent [__] for that
they're like hey here's this thing that
like you know that that we use for like
sheep's wall and it's like hey let's use
it on Gary over here yeah you know what
I mean cuz he pissed me off it's just
like hey cheap it's a cheap torture
method some of the N of those Native
American tribes it might have been
Lakota I think I don't remember which
one it was the crow they had something
similar to that they would just skin you
alive or FL Flay you alive with a
sharpened uh sharpened uh seashells yeah
that was one of the ones that they would
do yeah and if you the more you cried
out and screamed the harder they'd work
on you if you just grinned and bared it
like a man they would [__] uh you
gain respect they let you go that's what
happened they they tortur half your
flesh off yeah they tor some British
soldier I think he was an British guy
like Frank from hellis I think it was a
British guy who was in the America who
ended up in the American Army they
killed his whole party he was with a
party of [__] civilians I think he
was off duty or something the time and
he he bore the torture so well that they
they just let him go they respected his
ass yeah he didn't scream or cry he just
[__] bared it like wow we peeled that
[__] like an orange he just
didn't even say nothing he didn't detail
what they did to him they did some bunch
of [__] to him but they let him go
that's [__] crazy yeah [__] crazy
like I said I don't know how people come
up with this stuff man yeah let's indan
tries man look man you guys don't know
anything about Indians Indians were
[__] bad asses and they were like the
Klingons some of them especially Plains
Indians if you showed any weakness they
just [__] bore down more on you they
like strength that's the only thing they
respected they just wanted you to suck
it up and take it yep if you cried like
a [__] they just [__] double triple
down on
you yeah well you know mhm R said now
that's some hardcore old school deli
meat counter yeah you know what that's
kind of what I was thinking why would
you let that go to waste if you in the
Middle Ages you throw that [__] up on
the fire throw it up on the fire be
right there yeah now see I wonder about
that nice little slam thing put it under
the bread hey you hungry here have some
guy eating himself that's some head of
electri [__] well I think that there was
in the Middle Ages and maybe a little
bit before and after I think there was a
thing where like they would they were
going to burn the did at the steak but
first they would cut his dick off and
burn it and feed it to him wow and like
cook it and feed it to him yeah so yeah
I heard of him doing that too like I
said that is some hanal actor [__] right
there yeah that and that's some that was
that [__] that was like was it
wasn't that um what was that German
dude's name that that that weirdo that
wanted to eat the person and then the
person he looked weird that dude [__]
looked weird yeah you know I'm a big
Advocate it's like oh you know don't
judge a book by its cover but like that
some sometimes yeah oh yeah sometimes
when you look at a person you're like
yeah there's something that matter with
that person like he definitely looks
like that jeans don't lie sometimes I
mean sometimes sometimes but yeah now
I'm now I'm kind of thinking that uh I
guess like that that new Subway deli
meat slicer they have in there you could
use that for like [__] torture
purposes also please don't do that if
you work at Subway I'm just saying um
Also let's talk about some thumb screws
now I do have a picture of that now this
is kind of like yeah now this is one
variation of the thumb screws because
you do have some variations that are
like this that you can put a bunch of
fingers in at the same time um most of
the ones I think that people are
familiar with are just one that has like
one thumb in it or what you could put
their big toe in there too so yeah it's
basically just it's the same kind of
thing like I was talking about like with
the foot press where it's just kind of
like it's essenti it's like a vice
essentially it's just like two things
and it's just like a screw and then they
would like screw it now did they
eventually just keep tightening and
tighten that down down until until you
broke the the thumb yes yeah okay yeah
so no matter what was going to happen
you were going to get a finger broken
well not necessarily because I think
they were basically just doing it until
you confess to or you said what they
wanted you to say um if you didn't
confess then yeah they would absolutely
keep going until they smushed your
fingers yeah um and broke the bone yeah
because it would it would just it would
just like SM like smush your fingers and
then after it was broken wonder if they
kept going like to just to keep I'm sure
yeah I guess it would depend on the
torture like how much they cuz I'm sure
they [__] got off on it CU why would
you even want that job to St with to
start with if you weren't messed up and
I'm guarantee man these people knew that
this [__] really didn't work they were
just trying to get the
confession like we don't even care real
yeah right I think that's what was going
on well and I think a lot of it too
because I I was kind of thinking this
about how you know like the Inquisition
and like the Catholic church and all the
[__] they did and everything it's like I
kind of feel like there was maybe a tiny
tiny percentage of inquisitors and stuff
like that that were actually True
Believers and actually did believe the
[__] that they were spewing but I
think 99% of it was we just want
to one have power over people and also
like take their [__] because if you were
accused of heresy or whatever and they
executed you they took all your stuff
and when like all your proper another
thing is these dudes that are doing this
torture are supporting the will of the
Lord whatever their L local Lord was or
their local
King he they were giving him what he
wanted right he wanted the confession
probably and with that confession he
could take your [__] right that's what
he's just like well I just have to get
him to say this particular thing by
whatever means right and chances are you
were targeted already he's I don't like
that [__] I'm going to take a
[__] okay accuse him of this torture him
he'll make the confession I'll get well
that for real well that happened a lot
for like we did a show about the witch
trials that was very common yeah it's
probably it was um during that yeah it
was just like it was usually people that
were one like didn't really fit into the
community or people thought they were
weirdos or too like people with some
[__] that they wanted yeah and the
dumbass plees the plees and the [__]
peasants bought into it they're like oh
they were that person was guilty they
probably believed it of course but you
know the people ordered it knew it was
[__] there's it had to been I'm not
going to [__] unell my [__] my
[__] my European ancestors to think that
they were that stupid no they were just
[__] ruthless that's what it was yeah
two completely different things yeah
they just had their own reasons for
doing the [__] I don't really think they
cared if you did the thing that they
were accusing you they knew you didn't
do it they do it and I think a lot of
times they knew that you didn't do it Mr
88 said new 13:00 shirt occasionally
judge a book by its cover yeah yeah I
like that I actually like that follow
your
instincts well that because sometimes
like sometimes people that look real
weird are perfectly nice people but
sometimes people that are weird
looking you can tell the difference
between something or somebody who's
[__] sick yeah you know what I mean
[__] that's not their fault or
somebody that's they're in a condition
that tells you that there's something
mentally wrong all right doesn't mean
you attack the person does it just means
that you just you can't really trust
that person don't go anywhere with that
person that particular dude was calling
somebody we're talking he called
somebody to be eaten and that dude was
knew that he was going to be eaten I
mean I guess unless he thought the dude
was kidding he stayed after he got his
dick cut off the guy ate it he ate some
of it if I remember correctly um I think
he tried some I think he tried some of
it too but they said Well he kind of
burned it and he said it was like too
chewy and it wasn't yeah it wasn't any
good see that's what happens you have
all should have put it in the instant it
hurt though he was holding he it hurt it
was bleeding a lot well yeah that that's
whated happens when you cut off you're
deal with these
two German freakazoids man one wanted to
eat the other and they both wanted it to
happen yeah it was it was consensual
that [__] was murdered though man
murdering he still got in trouble yeah
of course because that was I mean that
was the argument he tried to make he's
like hey he was like there like still
though yeah and it was consensual but
still you can't let some dude like that
walk around no you can't you can't um he
got to go that's the thing and like I
said I'm look weird man I'm very
open-minded about people's fetishes and
about their sexual proclivities like
that but yeah like yeah and as long as
everyone's consenting I'm fine unless
unless somebody dies or somebody under
that's going into or somebody's a
captive captive then that's like a whole
other captives can't captives can't
consent no [__] underage people can't
consent insane people can't consent and
that dude that consented was insane okay
he he belonged in a hospital not on
somebody's [__] men help yeah yeah
big time yeah
and it's a sad situation other dude was
insane
too um but yeah
so it's just it's [__] up that some
people have like a fetish out of uh
stuff that they were doing back then
that most people would be like horrified
by you know what I mean yeah but yeah
here's something that I found that was
funny about thumb screws well it's not
funny but kind of um so the precursor to
the thumb screw
was called you're going to love this it
was called a Ply Winks SS which sounds
like a Teletubby yeah it sounds familiar
I remember this I remember that name oh
I'm going to get put in the ply wings oh
yeah that was not was some bad [__] from
what I remember it was it was like a
nutcracker for your fingers but for your
fingers yeah I think there was one for
your nuts itself though too wasn't there
when look like a spoon with a [__] V
with a spike on the yeah I
think looking at that [__] making
me oh Tom's starting to fidget he's like
thinking oh it went on one of your nut I
ain't going to talk about uh I yeah I
can imagine I don't have nuts but it's
like I can imagine what that might feel
like oh man oh that would be bad
yeah um but yeah I also found this fact
interesting was that kind of a famous
person that was subjected to um the
thumb screws was uh emisia gesi who is
quite a famous Baroque Era painter I've
actually seen some of her paintings in
person and they are quite beautiful
she's a female uh yeah yeah okay um and
uh yeah she it was early 17th century
now she was put under thumb screw
torture for a [__] up reason her she
was accused of having lost her
virginity but to rape like a dude raped
her right but she so she so of course it
was her fault like the dude didn't get
put in the thumb screws yeah she put
Magic on
him that's probably what they said you
know what I meanz you were so attractive
we got to punish you yeah it's it's your
fault you did it didn't kill her
obviously but um but yeah cuz the thumb
screws that was kind of the [__] up
thing about it what were they going to
get out of her though they just wanted
her to confess maybe that she had
Bewitched him or something yeah right
yeah cuz of course it's not his fault
cuz men are blameless gu what happen he
was from a powerful family they try to
I'm sure he was a painter
he's from a powerful family had money
they bribed the court said look we got
to get him out of this [__] so they
[__] tortured her to make her to
confess that it was her fault yeah
that's probably what happened and they
all knew it was [__] yeah that's
messed up but who cares they just
smushed her little
fingers yeah you know these people were
ruthless man that's what I mean they're
terrible never [__] go back down well
they're basically they're basically
cartels well yeah it's the same kind of
thing same kind of deal yeah Tammy says
she was probably out there showing some
some ankle
right no she was probably just pretty
she's just pretty had a nice dress on I
I've seen um well well she's a painter
right and she did some self-portraits
and I know that people are always going
to make themselves look better in the
self-portrait but at least in the
self-portrait she's actually gorgeous
probably was so yeah so she might have
been but um but yeah like I said you're
always going to make yourself look a
little bit better just like the
Instagram filter but you know what I
mean from Rena that's probably what
about what she looked like look there
are Roman and Greek sculptures of of
women of that
era they people people used to think
that they were they were idealized
sculptures that they didn't really look
like that and then Eugen Sandow who
invented bodybuilding proved it that no
this is how they looked because he he
replicated the look of the of body same
with the women they had beautiful people
super beautiful yeah not everybody
looked like like a hag back then cuz you
know and had [__] scabies and whatnot
some of those from based on some of
those Renaissance paintings of noble
noble women and young young ladies and
girls and [__] no they were real pretty
yeah had funny hairstyles but still very
pretty
so yeah if she if she painted herself as
gorgeous it was probably accurate that's
what I was thinking yeah you know what I
mean because people call [__] on it
they be like that's not you that's not
you so she so you have to make it look
like at least mostly like you like there
maybe just like a little idealized well
cuz I kind of feel like well it was
pretty common too for you know if you
got like a royal Patron you know make
you had to make them look good cuz you
couldn't make them look like a [__]
ogre right or they wouldn't pay you you
know what I mean it's like I don't look
like that you [__] like 40 chins and
yeah zits and [__] like that but
according to Roman statues statuary that
the good [__] Caucasians have not
changed much in how they look they look
about the same I mean you look at a
[__] uh bust of Emperor vaspian I
mean [__] that look like Norman
Schwarz and you could tell that that
wasn't an idealized painting of a
middle-aged man that's just how he
looked he looked like a
middle-aged kind of big guy yeah with a
smile on his face look like Norman
Schwarz C that's how they looked well I
kind of Imagine just from the people
that got painted because there were some
artists that painted like peasants and
stuff like that but it's like I imagine
that probably just like nowadays
probably like 80% of the people just
look like random ass [__] like
nothing special and then there was just
like 20% of people that were like really
goodl looking yeah you know well there
were Roman busts of females that were
Noble women they were gorgeous weird
hairstyles that was the only difference
little weird Tiara looking things and I
kind of like C I kind of like all that
stuff they did with though yeah but you
know they were pretty or they but like
you said the average person wouldn't
have been sculpted yeah so you had to
been pretty to be sculped right like
we're going to save this [__] bring them
take a picture of this that's what right
yeah it's just um you know other than I
was thinking of I don't know why I just
thought this popped into my head um
please somebody remind me who the artist
was like I know I have a postcard of it
somewhere but it's a very famous
painting can't remember what year it was
from 16th century maybe but it's called
I think the name of the painting is a
very ugly old woman yeah and it doesn't
look like it almost looks like an ogis
yeah you know what I mean I guess it was
a real person but there were some
artists back then that were interested
in painting regular people or ugly
people or grotesques so there there was
like a small thread of that which I
actually found really fascinating it's
actually a I love that painting actually
I would have a big print of it like the
woman's crazy looking but I kind of dig
it it's probably why she was chosen yeah
because it's like yeah she's crazy
looking I can't remember the name of the
artist though ugliest person I ever saw
was a
photograph of a person that was born
with syphilis from a mother that had
syphilis and that person lived in a
hospital their whole lives yeah and if
you ever seen if you ever an Iron Maiden
fan you ever seen Eddie that [__]
zombie on the cover that's exactly what
that dude looked like poor person not
their fault just well yeah of course ate
up with they didn't ask for that look
just like that look like a living corpse
like something out of a horror movie
movie I mean you just got to think that
it's like late 1800s early 1900s where
the photo was came from it was just
[__] scary as [__] just maybe I
should B I should find that photo
because then on when on a day when I'm
feeling when I'm feeling bad about
myself could just pull it out and be
like well at least I wasn't didn't look
like that poor bastard just a bone
chilling photo to see it that that
person lived like that looked just like
Eddie yeah off the damn [__] killer
album [__] it that's what it looked like
High Desert said ply wink sounds very
kinky oh yeah it does that's what I
thought I said I thought it sounded like
a tell I'll make another drink okay but
yeah I was just like it sounds so cute
doesn't it like you know sounds like
titly Winks like you know that little
game you play with the little discs or
whatever like nope going to crush all
your fingers ha jokes on you but yeah so
uh so there's that so uh speaking of
[__] that was used against uppity women
also got a thing called the scolds
Bridal um this is also called The
Witches Bridal or a gossips bridal I've
also seen it called a branx I'm not
really sure where that term came from
now this was not a fatal punishment this
was usually reserved I'm sure they
slapped this on men every now and then
but this was usually reserved for women
and it was usually reserved for women
that were mouthy that um that gossip too
much or argued or um I think they also
used it on women that were like kind of
drunks or something like that or you
know were too vocal in giving their
opinions or something like that so what
this was there were a couple different
variations of it but it was kind of like
it was made of iron usually and it was
kind of like a muzzle like it kind of
went I think I have a do I have a
picture of that I thought I had a
picture of that somewhere here it is
here it is yeah it looks like that
that's one variation of it now some of
them had kind of like mask on the front
that sort of looked like um like the
face looked like a suffering person's
face but this was a pretty I mean this
is a pretty standard like simple one so
what this would do they would put it on
the woman's head and inside the mouth
was like um a spike that pushed down on
their tongue so that what so they
couldn't talk they couldn't like move
their tongue or it would stab them in
the tongue
so like I said it was to punish women
that were mouthy or opinionated um you
know they wanted them to shut up or
whatever so it so it would basically do
that um also they uh another thing that
they would do was that they would put a
leash on the back of it so that the
husband or whoever had uh you know
accused the woman and got her in this
predicament in the first place could
like lead her around the town like as
added humiliation also they would hang a
bell on her so everybody could come and
look at her you know what I mean um you
know so it it's it's kind of like that
uh they also used it on women that were
like in workhouses and stuff like that
like if they were bad but like I said it
didn't kill you but it was just they
would basically put it on your face and
you couldn't get it off and it would
just put push your tongue down and you
couldn't really I guess you could kind
of swallow but like your mouth would dry
out and like you couldn't move your
tongue or it would get stabbed you know
what I mean and like I said they would
also lead you around on a leash and [__]
like that because of course they did of
course they did cuz that's I don't know
that's some [__] up [__] I I kind of
feel like a lot of the
um a lot of the torture methods they
devised and a lot of them were used on
men too but they seem to take great
Delight in inventing ones that would
[__] up women specifically you know what
I mean they were bad well I mean yeah
the gold bridal was used almost
exclusively on women um that was the
thing on the head that I saw yeah it was
a thing on like I said and it was it was
specifically made for women that
gossiped or that talked back talking too
much yeah that talked back they would
they would put that on you and and lead
you around the town by a leash and like
have everybody look at you sounds like
it didn't work and [__] like that it's
probably just a thing of humiliation
more well yeah that's exactly what it
was exctly that was probably easy way
out of some punishment you talking too
much we're going to put you in that [__]
come on yeah that's it well that's what
it was like husband would be like yeah
I'm I'm kind of sick of her nagging
me that's what that was another thing if
you were like nagging your husband he
could like yeah slam that [__] on her in
a way it's kind of funny I mean it's
well not for her it was
ITT it probably didn't hurt I don't well
no it was a spike but it probably didn't
hurt it was a spike that like push you
you just had to shut
up I wouldn't they were [__] back
there but yeah no
[Laughter]
[__] there nowhere near as bad as some
of the other [__] that was out there
though oh Lynwood Sly reminded me of
that a grotesque old woman that's right
Quenton mazis that's right I knew I had
his I have a post card of it somewhere
like in a little frame and I don't I
don't remember what happened to it I
bought at I bought it at the Met
actually because I think I saw it there
when it was there that's actually one of
my favorite paintings I love that
painting um but yeah so that was he
talks about ugly Duchess too yeah yeah
yeah yeah he talks about later on yeah
you must be behind yeah well no I'm just
I'm right here okay yeah the ugly
Duchess also know as Tes okay okay yeah
yeah yeah I can't stand have my glasses
on oh okay I'm just trying to scaming
yeah M or says damn opinionated women
right yeah you got gotta gotta keep them
shut up somehow talking too [__] much
put this on I'm a you're leading her
around town people
laughing well yeah people would laugh
and like throw rotten fruit at her and
[__] like that like yeah stupid shut
[__] up other women like you [__]
talk too much [__] you know other women
were over there trying to [__] trying
to [__] virt you signal yeah you talk
too much yeah you be quiet you be quiet
you you brought this on yourself yeah
you know that was going on Kens and [__]
yeah all the Kens
out oh my God that reminded me of that
of that [__] Karen that was at the
gas station the other day when we were
putting gas in the car oh her yeah she
was on her phone yelling at somebody she
was cute though I didn't see her I was
inside the car Tom was pumping gas yeah
she uh she look like she was like a
fitness chick [__] you you know you
could tell I mean I knew that without
even looking at her just from the sound
of her voice and like the tone of how
she she's a fitness chick little short
Fitness I could imagine an expensive SUV
yeah you know she was kind of classic
Karen yeah she was kind of like a a a
high aelon [__] redneck chick you
know talking [__] if she ever facetimes
that woman behind my back I'm just
G you tell that [__] to shut up you
know it's that kind of [__] you know the
women those women were fighting redneck
women fight well she was loud like I was
in the car with the windows rolled up I
still hear every word she was saying I
was pumping [__] gas Jenny's jalopy
and [__] and I'm [__] looking around
the corner like that and first thing to
pop around the corner is booty and then
I saw the rest of her and she looked at
me looking at I was like man [__] what
are you
[__] hold it down man [__] she's
yelling into the damn phone that's what
I mean it's like the whole [__] she
gave me a dirty look like don't look at
me when I'm yelling I was like
right well you know that they're yelling
like that cuz they want F attention they
want you know otherwise they'd keep
their [__] trap show wouldn't they or
they would talk in a normal tone of
voice instead of screeching I was
wondering who bought that SUV though I
don't know she didn't buy it I don't
know no she sounded like a her man
bought that she sounded like a real
estate agent yeah
maybe I don't know she just she gave me
a real estate agent VI I don't know why
I didn't see her like I said but it's
like says he likes opinionated women but
he's he's married to a passive one well
you know there's no conflict if if you
don't need any conflict then don't worry
about conflict you know what I'm talking
yeah not needed me and Jenny don't
conflict very much no not really no I
mean we kind of we we quibble over like
the camera and stuff like that but we're
just [__] around mostly I just don't
we don't take yeah she only gets
combative when she's drunk pretty much
yeah yeah she threw the [__] she
threw my Xbox controller the other day
Tru and I was like what the [__] well I
was so bre F no I didn't break it it's
all right she thought I disrespected her
but it was it was in her mind you did no
it wasn't in my mind now you were just
drunk you just read into it it was in
that's what they always say wait you
going to put a you going to put a scold
Bridal on me now so I'm not allowed Tom
would love he's like he's thinking about
it he's like yeah I need one of them
maybe I should get one of those I'm G
order one of them from from [__] she
from te order that [__] from Teo I'm
sure somebody you know what I'm sure
somebody on Etsy makes this stuff like
if if you to get into we got a Teemu
order in today Jen tried all the [__] on
it it looked [__] hot as [__] man got
her some really cool club dresses
they're all long black super tight
dresses that are cut all the way up to
the [__] side one of them goes up
almost just underneath the
armpit [__] it's got straps that hold
it together really good look nice new
pair of boots here they are right here
there they are right there
yeah More teu Boots yeah they're kind of
like demonia yeah yeah they're nice yeah
they're nice and then it cost [__]
half the price but the quality is about
the same just I was just excited because
all of the dresses you ordered yeah were
Smalls they were all smalls and I got
into all of them I they were all size
four so excited these little teu boots
these these sandals little sandal boots
I love those so cute we got those from
Shia in there didn't we that Shia but
it's the same company it makes them for
teu and Sheen one of those dresses you
got me today I'm going to wear to
momento on Friday night got the travel
pattern yeah it's like it's it's long
but it's got like slits up the side and
it's got like this white tribal like
pattern on the bottom yeah sleeveless
and it's got a [__] U kind of like a
priest collar or a turtleneck type thing
but it's real low cut and her boobs are
[__] she's got the boob shelf the
side comes out and it's slit all the way
past the [__] hip and it's got a
white tribal pattern on a black dress
looks great yeah it's cool looking I
love all of them were all of them look
good I thought but that I think that was
my favorite one all right so now let's
talk about the famous
the OG the rack now even though this is
associated a lot with the Middle Ages um
they think actually it originated in
ancient
Greece um and it has been used uh across
different uh eras across different uh
countries and stuff like that because
when you think about it it's a pretty
simple thing to come up with um I think
it became associated with the Middle
Ages largely because uh it was used a
lot of the Tower of London uh so there
was that which I've been to actually by
the way now there's a lot of different
variations of this I think the two most
common ones are just the kind of um
standard one you'd see like in a movie
or something like that which is just
like a big flat looks like a big flat
wooden dining table and it's got kind of
like
these like cranks on the end and you
know got cylinders yeah with with
ratchets right so like you tie the
people's wrists and ankles I think it's
called windless yeah yeah yeah on either
side and then you just slowly crank it
and it just just like pulls and pulls
and pulls um and I'm assuming that some
of them were strong enough to just like
pull your [__] right out of the I they
they were to dis dislocate everything
yeah which I'm sure was really really
horrible there's also one better being
bird though probably I mean like I said
this none of this is good none of this
is good but I could deal with this one
being burned alive would probably
be I mean unless you di alive oh yeah
yeah or like I said [__] like having
well I don't I it in not but I just
remember this one from a documentary
earlier they had this might have
originated in China but they did it in
the um in Europe as well where it was uh
the saw which is pretty much what you
think it is so they would take the
person and they would hang them upside
down for a while so all the blood would
rush to their head and like their upper
body and then two [__] would
make like lumberjacks and get on either
side of this big ass saw and start
slowly sawing the person in half
starting with their crotch yeah up and
because all of the blood had rushed to
their head because they've been hanging
upside down for such a long time it
would take a really long time for you to
die because you wouldn't like bleed that
much yeah from that so they would just
like slowly start like right at your
taint and they would just like saw saw
saw and it took a while yeah to die that
way so that and they had another one too
which again I don't think I even put in
my notes but I just remembered it from a
documentary earlier was that they would
make um a little incision in your
abdomen like about the size of like so
you could get a hand in there take your
part of your intestine wrap it around
like a dowel and then like pull it and
then slowly yeah and it had little it
had [__] little spikes on the dowel
so it wouldn't wouldn't lose grip and it
would take a long time for you to die
from that and it would just like slowly
pull your intestines out far as getting
cut in half with a saw they had another
one where they would take a dude and
they strap him up by his arms like that
so he'd be hanging and his feet were
secured to the ground and one guy get in
front of him the other get back with him
with like a [__] tree saw big [__]
with big teeth on the
saw and they'd start [__] doing that
like that and saw up yeah now she said
that they did when the guy was upside
down stay alive longer yeah probably the
original was just to saw up probably but
like I said when they thought it's like
oh hey if we hang him upside down
prolong we'll prolong the agony oo good
idea yeah um science [__] yeah let's do
that cuz like I said it does seem like a
lot of the you know early tortures were
pretty I mean they were horrible but
they were like pretty rudimentary but
then like some brilliant [__]
somewhere would be like hey you know um
if we did this and that and the other it
would take like so much longer for them
to die and wouldn't that be fun I just
kind of feel like that was um because
the thing about it was that a lot of
times when these people were being
tortured they didn't necessarily want to
kill them or at least kill them right
away they wanted them to confess to [__]
or they wanted that to punish them for
something so it would behoove them
because they got paid to do this to make
them last as long as possible so there
was kind of a [__] up art to T
torturing people and doing horrible
excruciating pain to them but not
killing them yeah um
which like I said very creative some of
the [__] they came up with but also
monstrous here's the weird thing we
talking about all this [__] torture
that these guys came up
with you also have to remember that
during the same period you had
people who knew about Evolution they
just couldn't talk about it they've been
reading Greek and Roman writings that
supported the idea that humans kind of
arose out of a quagmire of competing
animals and that hum and then and then
some of these guys
also believed that stars were other Suns
and that there were planets around them
and there may be aliens around those
planets so you they weren't dumb you had
some people that [__] knew exactly
what jordano Bruno got executed for that
for for telling people got [__] like put
through his lips and everything yeah for
talking about aliens he got burned out
the steak burned at the steak Yeah for
talking about aliens I read a couple
fought over and over again he would not
back up on really the church knew that
he was right yeah of course but they're
like they didn't want them telling the
peasants that so they killed him they
gave him many he was crazy Bruno was
[__] crazy he was crazy he was
[__] crazy but he stuck he was right
but he was crazy he was principled but
they gave him many they gave him many
opport unities to recant and back out of
that statement and he he wouldn't do it
he wouldn't and for no reason really he
should have backed out of the [__] and
waited a few years and he could come out
with another book just go somewhere else
just go somewhere else different yeah
I'm brano Juno he could have moved to
another another he could have gone to
another kingdom and been fine and his
work would have would have you know
still survived so I think he was a
little crazy but he was right Sons were
stars and there were other planets
around him the reason why the church
didn't didn't want that is because they
said well what about God does that mean
there's a Jesus on every one of these
planets to try to see save their souls
are you saying our Jesus is a copy yeah
yeah that's what they were ups that was
the problem I have a great book it's in
here some in in my pile of books about
him I think it's called the pope and the
heretic or something like that but uh
but yeah and they talked all about that
he had logical explanation he says well
maybe each one of them got delivered a
different message from God yeah but they
didn't want to hear that no of course
not because there could be no
deviation yeah from the Catholic version
of the deal well yeah they didn't want
any uh perception among the Rabel that
there was any uncertainty in their ranks
like they wanted to yeah we know all the
answers and you have to come to us right
there's only one Bible and there's only
one faith and there's only one so
anybody that came out and said well what
about this be like yeah you shut up yeah
we're going to nail your lips together
and then burn alive right it's pretty
much salute Bruno that's what I did I
read wouldn't have done that I wouldn't
have either but that's the thing it's
like a lot of people wouldn't have so I
was like well you got to admire his
[__] balls man he's remembered yeah
yeah got to admire as [__] we should do
a show about that [__] yeah okay
cuz I I read a couple books about I'm
like man this [__] was Hardcore
I I do not think there's just no way I
mean look if if I if I
came and believe and look my atheist ass
like going back to that time period and
stuff I'm be like I don't really think
any of this [__] exists you know what I
mean but it's like I'm not going to say
that out loud Jesus [__] Christ I
want to keep my head on my shoulders
thank you I'm pretty sure most people
back in The Honky motherland were like
that yeah they knew that it probably was
[__] yeah but they couldn't say
anything it was a totalitarian Society
like I said I don't want my [__]
thumbs crushed or my feet crushed and
like [__] molten gold poured down my
throat or nothing like that no thanks
the church was supporting
the oligarchy basically uh the
monarchy to go against the church was to
go against the monarchy the [__]
church was the control mechanism yeah to
keep the peasants in
line to deviate from the church was to
deviate from the king and the money and
the power your ass was going to die
that's what's going to happen in the
most in the worst most public way
possible and they were going to make an
example of like they did just defying
Authority yep it didn't have anything to
do with truth nothing do TR 88 said I
think I mentioned this before but my
first son was delivered by a cesarian
section and the epidural completely
missed my wife was completely cut open
and sat that way for almost 2 minutes
yeah so she could hear all of the stuff
oh I can't even [__] imagine I can't
because they make quite a big incision
you know uh Victor says the Spanish
donkey was similar yeah that's right
that's similar to the rack uh it's kind
of this I don't have a picture of it but
it's like this wooden wedge thing that
kind of looks like a donkey obviously
and it's got legs and you would sit on
it and they would weight your legs so it
would just kind of this triangular thing
like going up into your [__] taint
like all the time but yeah so so like I
said you know the rack pretty like
people pretty much know about that
sometimes uh if they thought the person
wasn't suffering enough they'd be like
hey I got an idea let's stretch them out
on the rack and also we'll start a fire
underneath the table so we'll also kind
of roast them alive while you're doing
that too cuz the rack wasn't bad enough
that's bad enough you know what I mean
so it's like well they were thinking
like I would do they thinking like I
I'll choose the rack pile some [__] well
we're going to add fire to the rack cuz
you choose the rack too much yes also
another other [__] they would do like uh
concerning fire was that they would take
people's feet and like then they put
like fat on the bottom of your feet and
then like [__] you know they you
basically like roasting your [__] ex
fire the fat would sizzle the body yeah
yeah yeah they would do like that kind
of crap wonder if you could walk after
that if you survived I mean you know
later on yeah it would it did it cook
your bones and they have to agitate your
feet that's what I mean it's like you
just have to walk around with like
[__] stumps and [__] you know I'm
sure they didn't keep any records even
if you survived some of this [__] it's
like yeah you'd be crippled for Life
pretty much and Gad green well that yeah
and and yeah maybe people don't even
think about that cuz I want to think
about that too like when we get no
antibiotics yeah there was no
antibiotics it was no real Medical Care
anything like that so it's like bad
sanitation even something as you
relatively innocuous like you know
comparatively as thumb screws like still
that would bust up your fingers you
wouldn't be able to fix them ever you
couldn't do anything with your hands and
you would probably just get it it would
just get infected you would get blood
poisoning and You' probably die anyway
cuz it's not like they're you know what
I mean yeah like you said they would
just get gang green or whatever I mean
you know they were just like living in
filth
so they didn't know they didn't even
know to like wash their hands or nothing
but yeah um so another thing they would
do too like especially with the with the
ladder uh style of the rack was they
would do essentially like what we would
call water boarding nowadays where they
would just kind of like uh pour water
into your mouth or put like cloth over
your face and like just keep pouring
water in it so you felt like you were
drowning so they would do that as well
tato was doing that so you know that's
fun uh also had the wheel otherwise
known as the Catherine wheel it's
usually uh named that because of St
Catherine she was one of the people that
supposedly died on it was martyred on it
um and she was supposedly the first
person that was marted on it I don't
know if that's the case or not now
apparently at least from what I read the
original idea for the wheel was that
they would take somebody like the
prisoner or whoever and they would lay
them in the road and then run over them
like with a like a big wooden wagon
wheel yeah and then they thought well
why don't we just take the wheel off and
also put spikes on it yeah yeah oh and
also like tangle the person up on it and
put them around it and then like hit
them with a cudel yeah yeah running over
that's not good enough and like break
all the see that's what I mean it's like
it started out yeah you the wheel
breaking somebody else whe kind of like
rudimentary oh let's just take them out
and run them over with a wagon wheel and
Crush their bones and stuff but then
they kept adding improvements yeah put a
fire on the bottom they got go through
the fire right that's what I mean um but
yeah it was very common too like not
only to put spikes on it cuz they're
like oo let's add some spikes cuz that
always is fun um but then they would
have like this big iron bar and they
would spin you around and then they
would randomly just like hit you with
this [__] iron bar and like break
your bones with it hey they tried to
break Simon Le Baron on the wheel didn't
you see [__] Wild Boy video he's on
the wheel going through the water yeah
Simon made it he did yeah almost drowned
he did that was the story yeah if you're
not probably just a story maybe uh
serious got stuck with it's not
dangerous make it's not dangerous to
make a a rock music video well yeah I'm
sure there were like tons of people
around being like um hey we probably
need to like drain some of that water
out or something like that but um but
yeah so so that's the thing and it
depended on what you did as well because
sometimes what they would do if you did
some crimes quote unquote cuz I'm sure
some of the [__] they did wasn't really
crimes but um but they would put you on
there and they're like well we're just
going to like [__] you up a little bit
and then we'll just strangle you to
death you know what I mean that's that's
where the term kudrass comes from like
you know like the mercy yeah which is
what they would they would do that with
burning at the steak too they're like
well we'll tie you to the steak but if
you confess and give your soul to Jesus
or whatever the [__] then we'll strangle
you first like so you don't burn alive
right so it was just it was kind of the
same thing although I suspect most
people burned at the steak actually died
from smoke inhilation I hope they did
probably what because there would been a
lot of
smoke I think they would have died first
I mean I hope they did because my Army
buddy that would suck too but yeah my
Army buddy Sparks he was My AG in Korea
I'm still in contact with him I showed a
picture of him earlier yeah damn Tom how
big is he he was like six too all right
[__] was a babe magnet [__]
had all kinds of girlfriend ended up
Maring this [__] fine ass black chick
he had a party at his house and the
[__] fire got started because
somebody let off some fireworks in and
it and it [__] and uh when the fire
happened he Evac he got everybody out of
there but he wasn't able to save his
dogs he and for the party he had his
dogs in the
candels and later on after the fire you
know what I mean [__] uh the he got
reassured he thought the dogs burned
alive but they didn't they died of
smoking
yeah and smoke hits you before the fire
does well that's what most all it takes
is a couple of breaths of that [__]
deep smoke and it [__] knocks you out
and I'm sure that's I'm sure it's not
pleasant but I'm sure it's a lot more
pleasant than like [__] burning a l
he heard the dogs barking and he was
trying to help evacuate him and his
buddies were trying to evacuate out of
there [__] Sparks is [__] he he
was [__] competent as [__] he left
the dogs for last but by the time the
[__] dogs ter came up he couldn't get
up there this it was just black with
smoke he couldn't see he could hear him
barking but then it and then the Barking
stopped that's awful yeah I don't even
want to think about that yeah they were
his babies raised them hand raised them
no one stopping me coming in here
getting and B bab two big old pit
bulls said real friendly pit
balls I mean I don't have no I don't
have no kids I got to save if I got fur
babies mhm nobody stopping me getting
into them sorry I don't care what
happens but yeah so uh so yeah what we
talking about so uh yeah the Catherine
wheel I think I had a picture of that
but everybody knows what the wheel looks
like next thing I want to talk about
this one's kind of [__] up and I feel
like people probably know what this one
is but I um don't see this one talked
about as much uh this one's called the
Judas cradle which is also a really good
song by spawn Ranch by the way um and
I'm pretty sure I have a picture of that
let's see that that's that thing right
there now by looking at it you can
probably imagine the fun stuff oh that
that goes up in your ass doesn't
it they make you sit on that don't they
you know it does yes oh man see I told
you that's my greatest fear man
I so this is this is the one that Tom
least wants to happen
in because it's going right up in your
booty hole or like right up in your
taint or whatever um yeah Judas cradle
is usually what it's called or sometimes
it's called the Judas
chair um I don't actually know when this
was invented but it was you know in
common use in the Middle Ages uh so yeah
we're using gravity in this one uh just
kind of like the Spanish donkey like
picture brought up earlier so uh as I
demonstrated it's this kind of wooden uh
triangular thingy uh looks like a
pyramid and uh hanging above it there's
like a little bit of a harness situation
so what they would do is they would put
you in the harness and then they would
lower you onto they would usually tie
your hands and feet together and then
they would kind of lower you onto this
pyramid here um cuz it was all on pulley
and whatnot like the
harness um so yeah so it would come down
like like I said right in your taint or
right in your butthole and uh or I guess
if it's a woman like right up in your
vagina or in your
butthole so you would have this tip like
up in your [__] thing crotch yeah all
the time and you couldn't really move
because they would like I said they
would tie your feet and hands together
so you couldn't really if you tried to
struggle or anything like that it would
just kind of push it down further um so
they would just make you sit on this for
however long they deemed necessary
sometimes a few hours sometimes a few
days to just leave you hanging there and
they kep handing you weights to hold uh
yeah and then they said if you weren't
uh sufficiently confessing or anything
like that uh they would either either or
put weights on your legs so it would
pull down or they would also put oil up
in your butthole so it would like go
down so it would be like Slicker you
know what I mean so it would like go in
more uh so they would do that as well
another thing they would do was that
sometimes they would like let you sit on
it for a really long time until you were
I'm sure like [__] screaming in agony
and then they would lift you off it for
a little while not because they were
like oh poor dude needs a break but
because you could remember what it was
so you could remember what it was like
to not have that thing your butthole and
then knowing that they were going to
lower you back down onto it again
because they thought that made it worse
like because then you would know what it
was coming because you got like relief
and you were like oh [__] and then you
have to do it again you know what I mean
so yeah um this was uh I don't know how
common this one was but um it's pretty
much I mean they did this a lot during
the Spanish Inquisition um I believe it
was invented by an Italian fella named
Marcil who was a lawyer which make your
own jokes here um you know what I mean
uh now they usually use this for uh to
punish Heretics which a lot of these
were used for but also used on political
opponents as well um usually took I
believe it usually took two or three
people to um to do this you know what I
mean to do this to a person because you
had one person on the pulley and then
one person like doing the other [__] and
like supervising or whatever so yeah um
so like I said adding more weight adding
oil doing all that kind of [__] now this
one was one that they kind of had to be
careful of cuz remember how I said
earlier that these torturers were
generally paid to it was their job like
to get confessions out of people so they
didn't necessarily want to kill the
person they just wanted to subject them
to excruciating Agony so there was a
real finesse if you want to call it that
to torturing the person without killing
them and this one if you weren't careful
I guess this would
would kill the person so they really
kind of had to be careful in the way
they kind of like use the pulley and
everything like that I just you weren't
in here but I said they would also like
take the take them off the pyramid for a
little while just to be like hey isn't
it nice to be off the pyramid and then
bang you know what then put them back on
there CU they get used to it CU they
would get used to it after a while and
then they'd be like hey now we're going
to do it again it's like Isn't it nice
not to have a thing up your butt yeah
you know what I mean but yeah so um yeah
and then they would also like some of
the torture would sometimes come around
like push on like push on like that like
so it was like like that which is like
yeah assoles that's what I mean it's
like how can you [__] do that to
another human being it's like it's awful
I don't even think I could do that well
I don't know I I don't know if I want to
say I couldn't do that to the worst
human being ever like yeah if it was Ted
Bundy or something like that I'd
probably do it gladly but it's like if
it was anybody else [__] no you'd have
to be a lunatic to do that kind of stuff
to other people yeah the people doing
worse man [__] you know Isis and [__]
with was doing worse to people
but you know right but they're lunatics
yeah well some people F like I said
ideology is very dangerous well that's
what I mean lunatic using ideology you
can hurt a lot of people anybody that
beli something anybody that believes
something so fervently that they are
willing to do kill other people over it
I mean I don't even care if the belief
is true or not that it's like that is a
messed up that's messed up right and
usually when you have these extreme
ideologies you make enemies cuz people
don't agree with you so then they have
to kill you for their own safety right
so you know ideology needs to be kept if
you believe something kind of keep the
[__] to yourself live it but don't [__]
with other people with it you know what
I mean well that I mean I just kind of
there's an element of control freak in
certain well that's what I mean it's
just better to just kind of be like Live
and Let Live kind of [__] you
want to have like a Buddhist approach
right the Buddhists have all kinds of
ideologies but it's about them it's not
about you they're not trying to enforce
it on you you they don't [__] even
prosize they said well when you're ready
for Buddhism you come to it we don't
come to you that's what I mean see I'm
down for that kind of that kind of
religion I have absolutely no problem
with which is more like a philosophy
purean pH it's just kind of like look if
if it works for you and you like it and
you know and you're not hurting anybody
knock yourself out you don't see
Buddhist trying to recruit right do
whatever the [__] you want to do like I
said as long as you're not hurting
anybody everybody canting everybody is
you know whatever do what you want to do
um but the second you try to like start
forcing on other people or anything like
that then you're going to have a problem
or when you're trying to tell other
people how they should do [__] cuz
that's not you I mean that's another
person same [__] doesn't work for all
these people so um here's something that
funny that this actually occurred to me
earlier when I was researching the show
Mr 88 said interesting that sodomy was
such a sin yet they created anal sex
toys of Plenty they really did um well
they saw it as punishment yeah they're
defiling you although you know some of
them were like doing that [__] for fun I
don't I I don't know
maybe not I think I think they were just
look at a Bosch painting there's a lot
of anal [__] oh yeah uh things going
on in damn Bosch painting it's about
hell yeah and hell is about going in
your
booty sometimes there's another new
13:00 hell is about going in your booty
going in your booty I mean cuz that
could have multiple yeah multiple uh
references there to all if you look at
them BOS paintings you have these
[__] animal humans and somebody else
is putting something in an animal hum
booty and the devil's looking and
[__] all kind weird sh they did some
insane paintings they were great
paintings they are awesome I love [__]
messed up like you look at like what the
[__] was this dude smoking he's trying
to paint hell yeah yeah like they [__]
him creative it was very creative yeah
very C they weren't stupid they were
just kind of [__] crazy yeah that's
what I mean they came up with some crazy
[__] crazy [__] but um but yeah well
well the fact that they thought of this
stuff is indicative to me that it was on
their minds so the fact that they were
so
concerned with putting stuff up in their
booty yeah I kind of feel like a lot of
them were doing it for
fun why would that even occur to you
otherwise to put that you know what I
mean I'm going to go the other direction
and say no I don't think they were they
had gay people of course but they kept
they kept that [__] low well yeah
because they would absolutely get burned
a lot of this stuff that's happening in
the mle medieval period
is a
backlash from what had been happening in
the Roman period well because they
thought it was too decadent yeah and the
church the church survived the Roman
period and uh the church was kind of
like something that the Roman government
tried to put together to keep the [__]
from falling
apart and uh later on after Rome was
gone you
had
aristocratic
European mediev you know Medieval Era
families getting their hands on things
like Roman statues and some of it [__]
like saders raping she goats yeah and
you know that kind of stuff and weird
statues of little men with gigantic
[__] dicks they didn't understand
they just knew that the Romans were very
sexual and that they didn't make
it but that Christianity did so
therefore the Romans were bad and
sexuality was kind of was bad definitely
homosexual and homosexuality and
bisexuality that was
bad uh so they were reinforcing that so
all the stuff about booty action that
was more about punishment than it was
anything else they I don't think they
were into that like Jenny saying they
were trying to force that on they were
trying to force that on to people who
they thought were Sinners and were
evil and that uh they were trying to
make it an unpleasant
experience so it was you know well
anything that's done to you against your
will an unpleasant experience I don't
care what it is you're like oh you want
to be a hoe then here put this in your
booty wooden pyramid yeah put this
[__] wooden pyramid up be such a hoe
I mean they were they were [__]
vicious so no this is what I can't even
imagine what that would fcking feel like
yeah like I mean no I can't imagine it I
can't imagine it right and it's
horrifying yeah and like I said you know
we watch a lot of porn Okay like just
the the business that we're in yeah and
and I've seen some girls put some
enormous [__] like up in their ass okay
so some people can do it but you can't
just do that you got to work up you got
to work up to that like I we were
talking about earlier today this girl
was putting stuff up in there looking at
the camera big old smile on her face no
[__] problem and I'm looking at that
[__] my [__] hair's
standing God damn I can't believe look
at the size of that yeah big she just
like sticks it right up it there she's
just like hitting it hitting it [__]
hard with gusto looking right in the
[__] camera she's doing it alone in
her in her room yeah and you know we're
talking about something the size of a
bowling pin yeah easily wouldn't it
bigger than that bigger than that I was
I was impressed yeah but in general the
size and shape about like a bowling pin
yeah the big end not the small end well
all of it together yeah a bowling pin
upside down is a better yeah description
of one of those things that's what I was
thinking yeah that's what I was thinking
yeah but um yeah so
so anything can be done with practice I
don't see too many of them putting a big
wooden pyramid up there no no that shape
is not made for yeah you don't really uh
want you don't see too many SE St shaped
like that for that very reason you don't
want edges on the stuff Zach could you
take a bowling pin upside down an upside
down bowling upside down like not the
smooth end the kind of fly rubber so
it's got some give to it yeah well yeah
you wouldn't want to put like an actual
bowling pin I'm sure although I'm sure
there are some people that can do it it
was a giant sci-fi animalistic kind of a
[__] dildo dildo thing but it was
huge oh yeah [__] 18 inches in L it
was so big that I was thinking that I
know this isn't going to happen but I
was like is that g to come out her mouth
yeah I was thinking for a second it
might come out mouth that's how long it
was yeah but I and and I know I know how
that big around that big around it it's
greatest but yeah it was big yeah it was
big you got some Anal Queens out there
we do yeah like I said it's kind of
impressive honestly yeah it's like a
[__] just from an anatomical standpoint
I was just like wow like anal evil Canal
well cuz like intellectually you know
that's possible but then like when you
see somebody do it you're like holy
[__] [__] I didn't intellectually
grasp that that was possible until I've
seen it it is I didn't think that was
possible until I see it it is possible
yeah it's you know not everyone wants to
do that
obviously and I I can't really I can't
really say I blame him but you know what
I mean yeah so remember how we were
saying before about like infection and
stuff so the thing about the Judas
cradle yeah probably like a lot of these
torture devices it's like okay so Gary
here is sitting on the anal pyramid um
for two days or whatever and he's
getting um you know all kind of what
what are we going to call it bodily
fluids on it blood um [__] you know ass
juice whatever um and do you think they
clean that they do not so then they
bring in the next person you know
alowishus or whatever his name is and
then they put him on the anal pyramid
and all of Gary's butt juice is still on
there that's ridiculous so you can
imagine that even if this didn't kill
you yeah you'd have like you probably
wish you were dead and you would
probably like get some horrible horrible
disease Victor's in there saying he's
not gay cuz he's a top
Victor I think that might have been
Victor's way on the SL on the slide
trying to tell me that he couldn't take
a reverse bowling pin well hey no shame
I mean I'm not sicking a I'm not scking
a bowling pin up there [__] it's about
what that's about how big it was was it
yeah yeah which like I said I I salute
that chick I do yeah um and I'm not even
being like funny or ironic or anything
like that I'm like that's a talent um
that I do not possess we're not talking
slowly we're talking
aggressively and that chick was like
maybe what 22 23 24 yeah I don't know
how old she was but yeah she's pretty
young little go and they're and they're
always like real skinny which like kills
me yeah I guess it's more impressive if
they're like this tiny little wafish
yeah little goth chick like Tinkerbell
looking [__] that sticks this
huge thing up their ass that's like as
big as they are yeah little flat chick
little flat chested goth chick I mean
it's just [__] crazy I said I like I
said I've seen some people put some big
[__] up their ass but it's just kind of
like that was the biggest thing that
I've ever seen anybody put up their ass
and I was just kind of like wow all
right but yeah so so what would have
happened what would happen if like a an
anal queen porn star yeah went back to
the Middle Ages and they put her on one
of these she'd probably just be like
what no problem she just open up relax
and just this kind of nice although
she's just riding it yeah this isn't
this isn't this isn't the only one I'm
just kidding the [__] I don't mean to
make light of torture it's just that
there's no way a pyramid that size is
going to go anywhere the one that
[__] you had to worry about was Vlad
teish or Vlad sepes yeah also that's who
they made CR Dracula after well yeah or
Vlad the
Impaler and he would just take like
a a
tree you know a
log probably about three or four inches
in diameter four or five inches in
diameter and kind of round it off and
grease it up tie you up put that up in
you and stand that [__] up in the
[__] ground it was kind of slightly
sharp it had been greased up the pole
and over time it would just slide up
into you and you were up there for days
evidently and it took a while yeah for
it kill it would take a while come out
eventually you die and it would come up
out of your chest cuz it would take a
while before it got to any vital organs
yeah well things would move out of the
way that's what I mean cuz you're
sliding so things move out of the way
yeah over time you know over hours and
days but eventually like come out of
your clavicle mhm and he'd have them
lined up around the road so when the
[__] ottoman Turks would come in
which one his land got invaded he's a
hero he not a villain [__] Vlad was a
[__] bad [__] uh I I respect
his resolve and uh in [__] what is it
turov visha I think it was the name of
the place [__] which is uh it's in
it's in it's in [__] Romania now I
think it was called I think it was
called Transylvania for a while but I
think it was originally called turov
Vista I think is what the name of the
place was and when the ottoman Turks
came in in there [__] one of those
[__] Sultan s sent an army out and he
saw all those impaled people and he
turned around he says we can't fight a
guy who's willing to do this kind of
[__] and he was doing that to his own
people you know if they disobeyed him he
he was a strict
disciplinarian I just kind of there was
zero tolerance for Crime it's [__] up
but it's just like I kind of love the
idea of like this Army like a bunch of
dudes on horses or whatever riding up
over this Ridge and then just seeing all
these impaled people and then like the
first guy just like pauses and he's like
nope
nope then he turn around and go back
well it was the general in charge he
said nah this is bad [__] and he turned
around wouldn't it be funny if they made
a movie about Vlad the Impaler where
that exact thing happened I would die
laughing the GU just like nope he went
through several Wars eventually got
killed but uh you know so I don't know
exactly what war that was where they
they turned around I'd have to go back
and read it again SP a long time he's
like yeah I'm not getting involved in
that yet yeah Vlad let's go back vad
let's go back home we we don't want this
we don't want the land that bad was from
the order of the Draco which is the gang
of knights that were [__] hired to
mercenaries what you call them today
they were hired to [__] defend
Constantinople in the Eastern [__]
Roman Empire from [__] ottoman
invasion of the Muslims it
was a different time man it some badass
times only the strong survived yeah Tom
wants to go back to those times I would
love that time as long as he had [__]
good hygiene but I had good hygiene I
just tried to [__] wash up be like
but nobody else would they wouldn't
though yeah everybody was gross be like
shave that [__] [__] godamn
dingleberries and [__] man come on yeah
can you imagine just like walking around
yeah even like the [__] even animals
don't do that even the noble women it'd
be kind of nasty probably compared to
what I was used to it' be
like shave your
legs
nobody's got deodorant nobody brushes
their teeth what the [__] is it the
Romans were all about that though the
Romans even the Roman men shaved you
know they didn't like body hair they
plucked yeah yeah they had everything
tweezed if you were high class yeah you
didn't have any body hair help you keep
clean so were the Egyptians the
Egyptians were like that too egyp like
like if you yeah and especially if you
live in conditions that aren't super
clean like yeah it's better to like
shave all the hair off because you don't
get like [__] no
and and just all kinds of other stuff so
it is better yeah and it's easier
because you don't have showers so you
got to do spongebath type deals yeah
they're scraping all the sweat off and
all that kind of [__] Danny Rowling said
Paris Hilton got impaled in House of Wax
Vlad style she died giving head that's
right I forgot all about that we should
probably review that movie one of these
days I remember quite enjoying that I
mean it's I like the original better but
um I remember being pretty
entertained by uh by that and I kind of
feel like it was kind of funny the way
they were just kind of like hey
everybody come see this movie and see
Paris Hill and Gill in a really horrific
way which uh I guess it kind of worked
because that's what everybody remembers
about that movie so you know that's kind
of what made me want to see it um and
you're also saying like yeah a Pringles
container yeah I have some seen some
girls put I've never seen anybody put a
Pringles container up their ass but I've
seen people put an equivalent size of
that like up their ass which hey if
that's what you want to do like I said
it takes commment you can't just do that
like right out the
blue Zack says uh oh I'll wait till Tom
com's back but I'm going to read it if
you want to be both impressed and
nauseated at the same time look up a guy
on PornHub called Kirk Jay or Kirk
Johnson okay I'm gonna I'm gonna look
that up I don't know if Tom will because
I'll probably be like o you know what I
mean he'll be like ah so yeah so we're
gonna have to like check that
out um yeah and then Lynwood Sly says
vlad's family was tortured and murdered
yeah that's right right he was just
seeking retribution so he took it to a
whole other level oh yeah big time yeah
we did a show about Vlad the Impaler it
was probably like I think it was like a
few years ago but yeah we did a show
about Vlad the andlor we do went about
uh Count's bathy we did all those we did
all that kind of stuff uh and then Danny
Rowling also says look up Mr 18 inches
Tony Duncan on adult sites okay like I
said I'm GNA look I'm going to look all
this stuff up I love that kind of stuff
but um you
know yeah Carl pans Ram is the modern
Vlad resolve for days that dude yeah we
did a show about him
too that dude of all like the modern era
modernish era serial killers that
dude I want to say he was almost like
the purest serial killer because he was
like a complete and utter sociopath you
know what I mean Carl pans Ram oh pan
Ram yeah yeah that's what he were tell
him yeah tanam was a Monster yeah he was
just like not like barely human not
really his fault but masterer you that's
what's kind of [__] up is just like if
he had had a normal upbringing would he
still have been cuz he had a horrible
horrible yeah upbringing just horrible
you still have to kill Panzer am if you
see but you yeah that's what I mean it's
more like euthanasia and preventing him
to [__] hurting somebody else because
he was like a natural disaster and
that's and we've talked about that a lot
before it's just like I'm not saying
that you know when somebody that becomes
a serial killer later on like obviously
if you knew them when they were children
and if they Ed like horrible because
some of them did uh endure like horrible
abuse and [__] like that like obviously
you're sympathetic to them back then but
when they become adults yeah and
perpetuate he'd roll up on dud of
violence he'd roll up on [__] dudes
who were like bums and vagrants up on
the damn train he he'd ride those trains
back in the [__] 20s I think it was
was it 20s or 30s I can't remember think
20s yeah might have been or might have
been slightly earlier I can't remember
yeah he'd roll up on him in the trains
to pull a gun on make them make them
have sex with each other and then kill
him anyway [__] uh he'd do things
like [__] pick up little boys take
them out on boats [__] do bad things
to them and [__] throw them overboard
and shoot them you know he was [__]
nasty like I said just a complete nasty
no no emotion whatsoever like everything
had just been like and he and what was
weird is that not his Target were
nothing but men and boys didn't hurt any
women he hated men and boys cuz he came
up in that damn orphanages and prisons
where they were [__] abused him well
yeah he probably didn't really have a
lot of interaction with women so he
probably didn't he had no interest in
women evident none at all but he hated
men and he had a SE there was a sexual
element to it well hi PO he was a
monster she's like she's smooshing all
over my feet and what and and and he
wasn't a badl looking guy if you saw him
he looked normal yeah he didn't look
like a crazy well he does in that one
picture that I'm thinking of like the
most famous pict if you saw him walk
around You' just be a normal guy but
yeah he would just look normal if he was
he was in pretty good shape for his time
and just he wasn't an old guy or
anything just that dude was the devil
yeah yeah he's pretty much the worst he
was the devil yeah probably the worst
out of all of them I would think
although other ones did more sadistic
stuff he was just in you know [__]
but he was
just [__] was dangerous like I
seem to have like no yeah redeeming or
human qualities whatsoever he was like a
damn gay
kamakazi like I said he was barely a
human being yeah after that point and
like I said I'm not you know it was
horrible what happened to him when he
was a kid obviously but it it removed
any empathy or any like human emotion
that he might have had to start with he
was at he was uh at war with all
men uh Zach says you weren't here when I
said this if you want to be both
impressed and nauseated at the same time
look up a guy in PornHub called Kirk J
or Kirk Johnson I don't know that one
what's he do well I guess we'll have to
look it up I said you can look it
up gonna be that's gonna be some gay
stuff there that's end times like he
does he's not no that might traumatize
me he might get TR might traumatize me
we'll watch animated gay stuff sometimes
if it's monsters if yeah all kinds of
[__] happens we're talking about
animated is that 3D stuff the World of
Warcraft gotten into that yeah World of
Warcraft I don't even play World of
Warcraft or anything like that but a lot
of the porn that people make that like
animated characters that are like
Monsters and stuff it's like I'm kind of
into that hot female characters with
werewolves and [__] minotaurs and all
kinds of [__] they're kind of fun yeah
and then I was telling him the other day
I said Orcs I think I'm starting to like
the animated stuff better than the real
people stuff because it's at least I
know that it's like these aren't real
people yeah and it's like they weren't
kind of like not enjoying themselves or
anything like that it was just you know
they're female Orcs in orgies with
nymphs and [__] human women it's like
Dungeons and Dragons yeah it's neat I'm
kind of which takes you back to the
Roman period when you see all those old
weird Roman statues of saders having sex
with women and yeah she goats and
[__] weird and the minur and that's
what they were talking about yeah it's
exactly what they were talking about
they had that they had all those same
ideas like they were living the Duds of
dragons life sure their religions were
like that yeah so it's like you know
nobody's doing anything nowadays that
they weren't doing back then safe [__]
the same [__] like all the furries and
stuff like that it's not that weird a
FES it's not that weird a werewolf is a
furry pretty much yeah I mean kind of
it's a man that turns into a dog yeah or
a wolf and then women have sex with them
yeah that's what a werewolf was or
sometimes several werewolves have sex
with one yeah yeah yeah and then you're
lucky to survive they're standing around
waiting you might get made into a female
werewolf they might eat you you don't
know but see that's the thrill the thr
like Vamp he might he might eat me after
this is over I mean man we saw this one
the other day it was like she got
kidnapped she was was she's in the woods
just like farting around doing something
and then like a
werewolf kidnapped her dragged her back
to the cave with other werewolf by the
by his knot yeah yeah yeah she jumped up
on her and and then [__] doggy style
and then turned around ran back to her
and then took her to the cave and then
all the other werewolves they had a orgy
werewolf animated it's not it's all it's
like but yeah I was just kind of like oh
and she was exhaust they were all
exhausted it was like pretty
entertaining I was entertained I was
entertained but uh but yeah I don't know
I don't know why I like those so much
and I like um because it's not real
people I like the uh the fanari ones too
Fooda yeah f f is a Japanese concept the
Fooda is a is a female it's called it it
translates basically as dick girl it's a
female with a with a large penis yeah
and sometimes they have both they
sometimes they have both male and female
genitalia at the same time yeah and uh
the Japanese came up with this [__] and
what they would do is they would do a
futanari version of anything like a
futari cat of a futari Catwoman yeah
yeah yeah or like you know what I mean a
futari [__] Wonder Woman you think
it's Wonder Woman then she draws down a
[__] big old 10 [__] on what are you
going to do what's going to happen now
yeah she's going to put the lasso of
Truth around you and she's going to
stick that di it's not she's not male
she's female yeah but she's just got
this [__] so what are you going to do
that's what I mean I kind of like those
two I like those
two that's the idea yeah
[Laughter]
yeah everything the Romans would have
liked that too probably yeah it's all
these sexual games sexual Mind Games
yeah yeah and like I said I about what
your limits are and what are you going
to do when this happens right you going
to run or you going to stay or what
what's going to you know that's what you
know that that's that's question well I
think that's the great thing nowadays
because the animation is so good and you
can do anything and you can get away
with anything because it's not real
people you know I mean it's just
animated so it's like you can put all
kind of crazy [__] in there and like no
one's going to get in trouble because
it's not you know what I mean it's not
real people doing it it's just some some
dude just made it yeah so I kind of like
that crazier you can do crazier [__]
yeah yeah matter of fact now that we
plug that that is all found on a on a
platform called Rule
34 rule 34 video you'll find it they got
all kinds of [__] and it's just dude's
creating it some of it's bad some of
it's real good some of the animation is
gorgeous yeah some of it's some of it's
a little rudimentary like you can tell
it's just like a student other stuff is
Hollywood quality but yeah other stuff
is like really good yeah yeah like I'm
shocked at like I'm just like wow look
at the [__] light and shade on that
kind of [__] you they got a dude named
[__] great M8 great mate great M8 is
how it's spelled and he does another one
called great B8 which is great
bait and he's doing uh what's the name
of that something or other AC Academia
yeah what's the name of that [__]
Academia it's some
Japanese yeah I don't know I don't know
much manga I don't know a lot about like
manga yeah and he's doing
that yeah there's a lot of character he
does really good animation yeah some of
facial expression and [__] yeah it's
like something out of damn Hollywood cuz
so I mean some of them are just kind of
like you know just a few seconds long
and they just Loop it and like the faces
are just kind of like yeah whatever you
know what I mean like like if it was a
real person but um some of them have
like really expressive faces and like
really good voice acting and stuff like
that like some of them are really they
to really took their time on it which I
kind of appreciate you know what I mean
yeah yeah so I I don't know we just we
kind of got into those sometimes what's
that General Butch yeah that's another G
but he's a good one yeah is it sad that
we like watch that we watch watch so
much porn yeah you can find General
Butch on that we know like the name of
the creators of theime you can find
General Butch on Twitter or X just look
up General Butch and and he'll he'll
he'll direct you to where all his [__]
is yeah you can wa see it for free does
superheroes and stuff yeah yeah yeah
they're fun they're fun all right so now
let's talk about probably the most
famous well other than the rack I feel
like this is the most famous the Iron
Maiden now
interestingly um and I don't know if you
know this or not but the Iron Maiden
there's actually a lot of controversy
about whether the Iron Maiden was an
actual torture device from the Middle
Ages or whether it was from later and it
was like extrapolated backwards yeah in
other words they were faking it right
yeah it looks like a fake to me because
that wouldn't be torture that would just
be
death you're slaming somebody Al well
the thing about it um you know the the
ideal Iron Maiden
is yeah it has spikes in it but the
spikes are ideally supposed to be short
enough to like poke all your [__] but
not kill you right away like so you're
supposed to just be like in there with
little spikes like poking in your organs
but not enough to kill you so you're
just kind of in there slowly bleeding to
death the ones that I saw were went into
your eyes yeah they did have some that
went into your eyes too like they
usually have SP like in your heart and
they had one off to the left where would
be your where it be your heart was
supposed but it might have a fake like
you said probably all the surviving Iron
Maidens are reproductions well see yeah
that's what the controversy is because I
didn't realize there was like such a
historical controversy about this until
I started like researching this show but
like I said ideally um the spikes were
supposed to be short enough that it
wouldn't kill you right away You're
supposed to like be in there like
bleeding to death for a while you know
what I mean um although it did have once
that would poke into your eyes now
according to many historians the Iron
Maiden was actually not a medieval
torture device because the first mention
of the Iron Maiden um that they know of
came from the 18th century and this is
from a particular writer named Johan uh
sankis I guess is how you pronounced
cben Keys something like that and he
wrote this um kind of guide book about
the city of nberg in Germany and he
mentioned one in there and he mentioned
something that had supposedly happened
back in 1550
this execution that had taken place in
nerber nurg and they said there was this
criminal I don't know what he did but he
was put in what um the writer described
as something that looked like a
sarcophagus but that had spikes inside
now this allegedly happened in
1515 but as far as I know there's no
record of that actually happening the
only record of it is from his 18th
century book saying that this happened
back in 1515 you know what I mean um so
the quote from from the book from the
18th century says the man was shoved
into the device and executed slowly so
that the very sharp points penetrated
his arms and his legs in several places
and his belly and chest and his bladder
and the root of his member m the root of
his member yeah the base of his dick
yeah pretty much and his eyes and his
shoulder and his buttocks but not enough
to kill him and so he remained making
great cry and lament for two days after
which he died so he was in there for two
days all right now
whether this was true or not because the
like I said there's a big debate like
among historians they're like now did he
just make this up or was this a real
thing or was it based on a real thing
who was this again um it was a writer
like from the uh 18th century Cur Johan
sankis he does he State his sources see
I guess not because that's what I mean
because 1800s is not [__] modern era
that it's not ancient era that's modern
well yeah that's yeah problems with that
story that's what I'm saying he's he he
had to he should have [__] named his
sources right so they're noting that
it's like there is as far as I know no
absolutely
confirmed Iron Maiden that came from
before that time because after that book
came out yeah obviously the idea took
off cuz people were like wow that's neat
yeah so then a bunch of like um museums
like started kind of like cobbling them
together yeah here's like making
something that looked like that and then
like putting them in there based upon
the story and then yeah and like even at
the World's Fair in Chicago like in uh
the late 1800s like they had one there
yeah so and I think people started
associating it with the Medieval Era I'm
not saying that they didn't exist but
they're just saying that they don't know
if they did no it has that has Hallmarks
of alleged yeah so they said now there
was one um that was called The Iron
Maiden of nberg which is probably like
the most famous Iron Maiden in the world
but but they found out that that wasn't
wasn't actually made until the early
19th century yeah so there you go um and
it was actually it was destroyed in an
Allied bombing in 1944 but yeah so they
found out that that was a thing that
means it's a myth now I'm not saying
that there weren't other devices like
that that it might not have been based
on yeah because there does seem to be
like there was something from um uh
Marcus atius from the fifth century his
book The City of God which was written
in Latin and he mentioned in his book
that someone was um
imprisoned um actually okay so he didn't
write the book but he's this is about
this general or whatever so he was
actually put in a box that had spikes on
the inside you know what I mean yeah
like a coffin kind of thing but so so he
couldn't like lean one way or the other
and he was like in there for so long
that he actually um couldn't sleep so he
died of sleep deprivation okay so triy
to stand up in right right right so yeah
you had to stand up in it you couldn't
like lay down so they're arguing that
that's kind of like the same concept as
an iron maiden and that was from the
fifth century so maybe that's where he
got the idea from there's also another
device that was called um that was from
the 13th century that was called a
barrel of Shame uh or a what a sh what
is it called Sha Sha Manel or something
like that and it was just kind of like
this big barrel thing that they like it
went up to your neck and then it kind of
came out like your legs could come out
but they just like put this thing on it
was more like a humiliation thing
although I have seen other variations of
it that they put you in this barrel and
they left you in there naked for a
really long time so you'd eventually
like get all infected from like [__]
and pissing like sitting in your own
[__] and piss yeah um so I don't know if
that was a factor as well is that where
is that where the three sto just got all
the damn run around in a barrel cuz you
lost your clothes maybe so that might
yeah cuz that was kind of a thing wasn't
it like a barrel that had like the
barrel on they walk around cuz they
don't have any clothes yeah why a barrel
but it yeah it might have been because
of that because that that was usually
like not a real like I said that was
more a humiliation thing like if you
were a drunk or something like that
right okay well they would put you in a
barrel based on what just what your
research right there I'm going tell you
there was probably no iron made yeah
that's the same like obviously they
exist now but it it wasn't like a
medieval torture probably made that was
that's exactly the same effect that
happened with the concept of the
Ninja oh yeah we show we did a whole
show let me pee real quick while you're
talking
ninjas J the Japanese believe that
ninjas
existed based
upon their reading of old history the
Shinobi all right and from the the
Shinobi the Shinobi is what the what the
ninja were based on but if you actually
read the original Japanese story what
they're talking about they're talking
about regular military
scouting uh [__]
tactics sending guys in to scout an area
out uh while the enemy's asleep you set
a fire in [__] part of their [__]
defenses and start burning them out and
Destroy some of their [__] supplies
and [__] interdict [__] supplies
that are coming into the [__] castle
that's just regular military operations
that you that you use Recon cast and
[__] for that all right um based on
those stories they came up with the idea
of the
Ninja but there real there there
actually were no
ninja when you think of when you think
of ninja you think of doing a damn
[__] black [__] outfit and a sword
jumping out of the shadows and [__]
attacking
Samurai that didn't exist the Japanese
thought it existed but it didn't they
invented it based upon on their readings
of
History the reason why it was black the
outfit if you know anything the [__]
s will tell you I think he might be ex
infantry but I know he's ex Army black
is not a good camouflage at night it
doesn't really blend in with what's best
is [__] green green and
gray the reason why the Japanese believe
that the ninja war black is because in
Japanese theater the stage hands a word
black
and when they recreated Ninja's attack
they just used the [__] stage hand
who was dressed in black fighting the
main character and you couldn't see him
that well and that was kind of the
interpret they were trying to depict a
person who was fighting from the Shadows
but there were never any
real Armed Forces fighting in black
uniforms and that they were [__]
mercenaries that were hired the oh well
[__] we need this Mission done let's
hire the the ninjas to do it no no
Japanese warlord would hire [__]
third parties that they couldn't trust
they used their own guys to do all
that but
eventually over
time the Japanese came to believe that
ninjas once
existed but well that's what happen
years like stuff gets that Iron Maiden
story is the same I kind of feel like
maybe yeah um this really does seem like
and I'm not saying that it couldn't have
existed because believe me like people
in the Middle Ages came up with weirder
[__] than that um that particular one
sounds fishy but that particular one I
think that was a
later invention like it just kind of
came from a fictional story and then
people were like oh that's a neat idea
let's make one or something like that
but it did come from some real [__] like
I said because there was some stuff from
the fifth century that talked about not
a you know sarcophagus but like a box
that had like spikes inside and also um
I guess there were like a bunch of um
really old uh fairy tales like from the
Early Middle Ages and stuff where it was
pretty common for um like evil
stepmothers in particular to be kind of
like sealed up in like a box or some
kind of Cask like a wine cask or a
barrel that had spikes on the inside and
then like they were kind of thrown in
the river or whatever so it's not like
the idea came from nowhere it's just
that that particular thing that looked
like a sarcophagus that open that had
spikes in it was maybe not a medieval
torture device but something that came
along later and then people made it but
like I said there's still like
controversy about that because there is
some um there are some people that argue
know that they had some that they think
are from the 12th century that were
actually used and stuff like that but
I'm not really sure it does seem like um
it was just kind of one of those things
that was kind of fictional but like I
said it sounds totally plausible because
uh because they came up with some
[__] crazy [__] the thing is that it
doesn't really sound that c if there was
an Iron Maiden there would be a long
history of it being mentioned because
you know that the wheel existed they
mentioned it you know that thumb screws
existed they mentioned it yeah well they
were old wood cuts of people being
subjected to right it it based on what
you said yeah the iron B was probably
invented later on yeah in hindsight in
hindsight there was a [__] like I
said there were like rudimentary
versions of it prior to that it's not
the same thing though but it's not the
same exact thing right not the same
exact thing so here's another one that I
think I have a picture of this one here
is called the Scavengers daughter I'm
pretty sure yes I have a picture of that
oh man they got those for sale on damn
sh they do we need one of those yeah you
think yeah I'll roll you over today you
going R yeah you would love it
yeah this looks like some fetish [__]
now that looks some fetish but I'm sure
it was much less fun back in look at her
face she's just kind of she she's just
dealing with it is she praying Pro oh
yeah maybe I think she's praying maybe
that's what it is so they're pretty sure
they know where this came from uh the
reason it's called the scavenger's
daughter is because the guy that
invented it was named skevington so I
guess it just became kind of bastardized
over the time so it's sometimes called
skevington daughter as well um so this
was actually invented they know who
invented this um by Sir Leonard
skevington who was around uh during when
Henry the e was during during his Reign
now skevington was actually the
lieutenant of the Tower of London at the
time and he was probably like like an
ass kisser and he's like hey I'm going
to invent a torture device I'm going to
get a [__] promotion or whatever um
now what this was they often call this
kind of like the reverse rack because
what it is it didn't look that bad in
the picture but what they're not really
showing you
is that when you were in it the frame
could like fold up so it would
essentially kind of like squish you this
way whereas the rack would stretch you
out this way this one would kind of like
do that you know what I mean like kind
of forcing you up into uh a sitting
position or like a or like a putting you
into a ball like without your consent
you know what I mean like it was kind of
it would do that so you could adjust it
you because it was like a hinge and like
you could um there was like a screw on
the side and you could just like tighten
it and tighten it it would just like
pull you together pull you together like
that like pull your knees like closer to
your head so it would do that um until
and eventually it was strong enough that
it would crack your uh ribs and crack
your breast bone and possibly dislocate
your spine also um they said that
sometimes when it was used uh blood
would come out of your face and your
fingertips so uh there was that too
Henry vi8
was apparently a big fan of using this
one on people that were um accused of
treason against him so that's nice um
but yeah so I got to May answer [__]
U Sly yeah Sly says there was no ninjas
wow you yeah and we did a whole show on
that uh just look up our show called bu
bullshido the [__] right bullido did
we talk about ninjas on their own show
or was it all the bullshito I think it
was all in the bullsh the [__]
that's in the martial arts scene yeah
that was a fun show to do it was really
fun yeah and I detail it [__] more in
bullido because it was the information
was more fresh in my mind
um but no there were no ninjas there
were special operators basically in
Scouts that did a lot of
[__] based on the stories of those guys
the the Japanese created ninja ninja
came later but only in the modern era
there were something that were always
legendary like you could go find some
[__] guys calling ninjas right there
like FID Kim calls himself a [__]
ninja he's a [__] hoax you know no no
he's not I could beat that dude's ass I
could have beat that dude's ass when I
was a little kid all right he was not a
ninja there aren't any ninjas there
never really were there were just Scouts
Recon soldiers type deal but he made
money out of the stuff so the closest
thing to a Ninja really was probably a
geisha a hooker
cuz she could sell information she's
sleeping with the Enemy and you pay her
what do you say when are they coming
what route are they taking when will
they when do they plan on attacking that
was [__] that was really where
Ninjutsu [__] happened I kind of feel
I kind of feel like sex operatives are
really underappreciated it's the best on
women the best role women are used in
militaries to take place of men and
support roles places where you don't
actually need a man to do that women do
that but when it comes to [__]
Warfare and combat and Body Count sex
operatives sex operatives cuz they are
sleeping with the damn enemy they're
Sleeping with the Enemy and they'll and
for the right price they'll tell you
what's going to happen if they know you
know but that and and they'll know from
weird ways by KN where you are the same
thing with Korea man [__] the Korean
brothel they were all [__] working
for the Korean the South Korean
intelligence and they were they wanted
to know what we were doing and how good
we were doing based upon what the [__]
did you ever tell any of those girls
anything well they know they know what's
happening just by your presence yeah
they you know what I mean they're like
yeah they're not dumb they're not dumb
they're like what unit are are you with
the 506 okay so they know on this date
the 506 four guys so it's just it's
simple [__] so if somebody needed TR
activity based all of the girls at the
brothel would know yeah just Bas they
trct troop deployment and activity based
upon who's in the club right when yeah
and who's got money and who
doesn't that kind of [__] we were
talking about his experiences in the
Korean brothels the other oh
yeah I had game before that but [__]
no I had I got appreciation for the
Korean girls he was single then we we
were in our army and they were in their
army yeah and it was a whole Army of
Korean girls that were basically working
for their
country uh to get every bit of money out
of our pockets and into not so much
information they just wanted information
and money they just wanted money money
and information and they wanted to know
that they were being backed up that if
we were protecting them that's all it
was Lynwood SL said thanks Tom I never
told the Korean girls anything in Korea
they tell you she know but you tell them
[__] without having to say it just where
you are I had girls telling me when I
was going to deploy yeah cuz they knew
the patterns right you know yeah you
know oh yeah you'll be doing this next
month really yeah it's like I didn't
even because they've been there for
years I've only been you know only been
there for months and they yeah they've
seen them coming they knew they knew the
pattern right yeah so they knew more
about it than you did exactly which is
kind of hilarious we were kind of we
were talking about it
because should I should I even say this
because I was like because Tom was
wondering or I was wondering I said I
wonder if you have any little Toms
running around out there anywhere well
they wouldn't be little anymore
obviously they' be adults probably not
there but um but you said maybe that was
probably the only possibility there were
a couple of them that weren't
prostitutes right there were girls that
were pretended to be prostitutes trying
to get laid it's like yeah if one of
those girls had gotten pregnant and had
your kid you wouldn't know about it no
the thing is is that they didn't have
kids the way you do here I think they
would send him to an orphanage and then
they would send him off to the United
States so they'd probably be like no way
to track you no way track cuz I was kind
of curious I and they wouldn't be in
Korea they'd be here like I said they'd
probably be like 30 years old by now cuz
they didn't want us in purifying their
damn Jean Pool right I got you so they
would have all been sent back to the
United States yeah put that half white
one we're gonna put that yeah put that
[__] white people so I was like
wouldn't it be funny if like I said
wouldn't be funny if there were like
little unknown little towns running
around out there Brazil's a possibility
also oh yeah that's true yeah more
likely Brazil that was more prodigious
at that time young younger
more that's true yeah like I said he's
like J Jen the [__] you could
have Brazilian girls would have been
more appreciative they you could have
like a whole line out there that you
don't know about Brazilian girls would
have been more appreciative they' have
kept it yeah yeah and then not told you
well I wouldn't have been to find him
but it probably didn't know their name
they didn't know my name right that was
in a time where you could just hook up
you don't really know who this is they
don't know who you are it's like a one
night thing right yeah so it's a total
possibility it's possible but I don't
count on it I consider myself to be uh
to not have any
Offspring yeah but we were just like
talking about it one day just because I
thought it's so funny man because women
seem like you might have another one out
there and then they [__] they get
like this [__] warm feeling in them
that I might have I don't know if it's
so much warm it's I it's not warmth it's
just I'm just kind of curious I'm
curious to know what a what a a little
youu would be like a [__] well that's
a
given that's a given I think your
[__] jeans would pretty much like
override anyone else's [__] right
jeans you know what I mean I figured but
I would just be curious and be like oh I
wonder they would look like and what
they would be like like other than being
an [__] which like I said of course
they would be an [__] but
um cuz Tom's an [__] but he's like
proud of it but he's a he's a sweet
[__] though it's a it's a weird it's
a weird
combination and it's like well the thing
about it is like he's an [__] but he
knows he's he's very self-aware about it
and he's like kind of makes a joke about
it too so it's like I don't know it's
almost like not being like an actual
[__] but just being like playing one
on TV kind of I don't know it's not
exactly like that but that's sort of
what it's
like so uh so yeah so what were we
talking about okay so this this uh
scavengers thing yeah scavenger's
daughter like I said it doesn't look
that bad from the picture it just looks
like a fetish thing because I think I
even sold some of those on my Amazon
store when I used to sell sex toys it's
a pretty common thing but like I said
what you can't see from the picture is
that you can screw it and it essentially
like makes you fold in half so like I
said it's kind of like the opposite of
like the rack it's like squishing you
together now the next one um I think
this one will probably not need too much
explanation because this one is just
called the breast Ripper the breast
Ripper ohly [__] um which yeah and I'm
pretty sure I have a picture well I
don't have a picture of that but I have
a painting of that uh yeah breast Ripper
there it is um so basically just like
some clamps that's the nipple clamps and
we're going to um yeah which like I said
I know nipple clamps are a thing I used
to have they pull the nipples off yes
they did oh and some of them were larger
these are actually kind of small yeah
the ones that they were depicting here
look at that chick's face she's just
kind of like don't do it well she even
she kind of looks like all Serene and
[__] it's going to happen here we
go I'm sick of this [__] man why are
they always pull up my nipples they did
that to dudes too though imagine right
um it almost overwhelmingly this was a
very female Centric um the thing about
it was that during the medieval period
like I said yeah they did a lot of
torture to dudes and stuff but they seem
to take particular Delight in doing
stuff to women's breasts and vaginas um
they because dudes invented it of course
well yeah so you know they were getting
a sexual charge out of it even though
they wouldn't probably admit that to
themselves but yeah they would either
Lop your tits off or they would burn
them off uh they did that too or like I
said they had this breast Ripper thing
the one that you saw in the painting
there those were kind of smaller those
were like the the nipply ones but they
had some that were like bigger clamps
where they would basic basically take
your whole [__] tit and then they
would just like clamp down and just rip
the whole [__] thing off uh so they
would do that as so so breast Ripper it
was a very um but yeah so it did seem
like that's like some other toolbox
Murders Yeah well yeah I that's probably
where they got a lot of their IDE dud
did this did that [__] with a pair of
pliers yeah lynw s said Jenny you can
still have children no I can't we don't
want it killed I one I I I have never
wanted children my whole entire life um
I when I was a teenager I was like no
not for me too put over that [__] but um
well and I'm too old to have children
now anyway I you say an adopt oh yeah I
I mean yeah but like I said I think I'm
I'm just too old to put up with that
yeah we don't put up that we don't have
time holy crap we got three cats that's
that's enough they they're enough of a
[__] that window closed for I can't
imagine you're really supposed to have
kids when you're probably in your 20s I
just I would when you're young and dumb
and have a lot of energy yeah I mean and
I still have like a lot of energy I'm
not saying that like for other things
for fun things but um I don't really
have a lot of energy to like follow a
kid around I I just yeah [__] um the
just the thought of it like kind of Jen
and Demetri bums me out Jen and Demitri
their daughter was like a little kid
last time we saw her she's like [__]
18 now and and is pregnant and got a kid
and I was like I went to Jenna how the
hell why'd you let that happen and she's
like no no no it's good let let her have
her kid now get it out of the way
because that's what she did yeah cuz now
she's like 40 something and she's and
her kids are grown yeah her kids are
grown she's everywhere but she's fre
looks fantastic yeah yeah yeah she's
she's she's still going out to club and
clubbing and stuff like that and her get
that [__] over with her early she done
yeah well I mean that's kind of what my
parents did I should have done it real
early they had me when when they were 18
yeah um you know so well and they had a
bunch more too three more but my mom was
still relatively but my like I said my
mom loves kids I didn't get that Jean
yeah I didn't she not only had four kids
of her own but she also ran a daycare
for a long she just can't get enough of
them yeah and I was just kind of like I
don't okay yeah like I said I didn't get
any of
that I like kids I just don't have time
for my own yeah it's a um that's what I
mean it's and I'm not like [__] on
people that want to have them because I
know a lot of people do but it's just
like it seems like too much work and too
much worry like I said I can't I I I
can't sleep at night like worrying about
the cats sometimes so I can't imagine
like having human children it that's
having kids is a young people's game I
was just like yeah you have to be kind
of like too dumb too to know what's
going on to know to really like worry
too much about it because I at my age
I'm just kind of like oh my God like I
could I would think of every single
worst thing that could happen you
know which yeah well another thing is is
that [__] you have one now we don't
live long enough to be able to help that
kid that's what I mean it's like we're
already in our 50s it's like yeah
technically we could probably live
another 20 30 years but still Yeah by
that time we can't re be much help yeah
we wouldn't really be much help to them
so I do kind of feel like it's probably
better to have them you don't have when
you're young yeah I you know you don't
have to have when you're 18 for Christ's
sake like my mom did you just look at
the statistics you look at the but it's
probably better to have them like when
you're in your 20s you look at the
statistics if a woman that are happening
now if a woman doesn't have them by 30
there's about a 60% chance she'll never
have them and when she hits 50 if she
hits 40 she
won't so uh no people in their 20s that
are supposed to be having kids when you
hit 40 you have to kind of worry about
health problems cuz it's not going to go
not the woman's best time now I mean
it's it's a lot better nowadays um
because you know we have have a lot more
obviously like metal medical technology
and stuff like that that can help you
out if you're older if you really want
to but it's a much bigger risk like the
older you get and really once you get
past 35 or 40 um it's not the best idea
right and and the risk is mostly that
you know woman at the 40 she'll have a
kid but it won't be the kid she wanted
uh you know it's not quite the best eggs
the best eggs have gone by that time and
even a guy a guy can have children
forever yeah until they are dead as long
as they can still shoot a load yeah but
they could be [__] 90 the quality of
that sper zo is not as good as it was
when he was yeah I mean everything 18 19
when you're when you're older obviously
everything kind of wears out a little
bit yeah but you know what I mean um
wait a minute Tammy said had my kids at
22 and 24 yeah good weird now that my
daughter is 31 yeah yeah you had you did
it right do it young yeah well I mean
and you're free well like I said what
you were saying before it's usually I
mean I I'm maybe unusual in the fact
that I when I was a teenager I grew up
around lots of kids so it's like she had
kids I had siblings I had a million
cousins my parents rent a daycare and so
I saw every day like what it entailed
yeah and I was just like you know I just
I don't think this is for me this is is
not really what I want she did her Duty
yeah so it's just kind of like and me
and Jen let met later in life if you're
new to the show so yeah I think I was 38
or 39 when I met you yeah that's about
how old I was so well no you're a couple
you're a couple years older than 41 40
around that time what are you three
you're three years older than I am I
you're three years older so we were we
were already out of the game really I
yeah I was already I had been married
for 14 years what you know me and my
first husband this this is our second
marriage we kind of talked about having
kids but we weren't real serious about
it CU I was like look I don't really
think I want any he didn't really want
any um you know what I mean I it's like
it we liked clubbing and stuff like that
too like even with my first husband so I
was just kind of like I don't really it
would kind of really put a a crimp in my
lifestyle um I don't know I'm just not I
don't think it's cuz I'm selfish or
anything like that it's just not really
a life choice that I ever that ever
really appealed to me and I get that
some people like it but some people
aren't built for it yeah I just I just
never even when I was young I was just
kind of like yeah not for me cuz like I
said I was around kid I was around kids
all the time yeah you were trying to be
free from it yeah so I was just kind of
like and I'm not and I loved my siblings
I have three younger siblings and um
unlike a lot of people with siblings all
me and all of my siblings we all get
along look we all just went to Disney on
my birthday we had a [__] blast yeah
um we are all very alike even though our
ages are very are you know we're very
far apart in age but we're all very very
very similar so whenever we're together
we just like finishing each other's
sentences and we like know each each
other's thinking and stuff but it's just
kind of like so it wasn't so much them I
think it was um being in a daycare um
you know being around cousins just being
around children all the time even when I
was a child myself or like a little bit
older that I was just kind of like I
don't it's too much I don't really like
all the noise I don't like all the chaos
I don't really like all of that I like
to see other people's children is that
cute kid that's a cute you care that's
good enough I'm s now take them away
yeah let's get back to this let's get
back take them away so let's do
something else so uh so yeah so we were
talking about the the breast Ripper yeah
which like I said um just as the name
implies pretty much a clamp that um
tears your tit off so yeah like I said
they they like to do stuff to women's
tits which to me that implies like I
said there's a little bit of a
fetishistic uh kind of thing going well
psychologically these are many torturers
and that's something is different about
this person is that they're a woman they
got these tits so we do something with
that it's calling attention to it I mean
why do you think during all the witch
trials and stuff like that one of the
first things they thought of hey let's
strip this woman naked and look for
witches marks they want to see him naked
sure and they have religious
justification for doing so I mean just
at least be honest that it's like you
just want to see naked ladies yeah come
on you just want to see naked ladies and
poke them with needles yeah although
there's a lot of heroism during those
stories too CU they had guys stepping
forward [__] defending some of those
women going they did yeah going nah this
this here isn't right they had one
military Guy step forward save the
[__] young girl from this
[__] but then the then the Witch
Hunter turned on another woman and went
that way and evidently he didn't save
that one because he figured that saving
one was enough if he saved too many of
them he'd be accused well that was the
problem and that's why a lot of people
didn't step up because well it was just
kind of like this feedback loop it's
like the second you stood up and said
hey wait this is [__] up like this is
an innocent woman oh well you must be a
witch
too the devil we're going to cut your
dick off and wi finder had to make his
money and if you got in the way of his
ass too much he'd [__] you up he he he
had they had the [__] all pre-planned it
was a scam of course scam it's a just
like pretty much everything else like
this it's always like a scam to make
money and uh and get property based on
the evidence that I that I remember
seeing that [__] a lot of people knew
that it was a scam but they were
afraid because that scam could kill you
yeah you wouldn't want to like run your
mouth yeah about it like I said you'll
get accused hey'll accuse you and part
of the people will believe it and then
they'll [__] get you of course it's
just um there's a great in uh Michael
shermer's book why people believe weird
things he has a whole chapter about
witch panics and he talks about the
Salem Witch Trials he talks about the
satanic panic and he talks about how
similar they were and how they work like
how they build up like how it comes to a
crescendo like how but he's like there
has to be and he's like and this has
happened over and over but there has to
be a critical mass of people standing up
and saying hey this is [__] before
the tide will turn the other way you
know what I mean he's like but a lot of
times it takes a really long time but
you have to like reach that point of
enough people standing up and saying hey
we don't want to do this part of human
nature right but he like it happens over
and over that even happened with the
[__] uh
dancing
diseases where people were somebody
wants to do a show about that too
dancing themselves to death yeah and
then you see the dance and then you
start dancing until you die until
somebody [__] puts an end to
it humans are [__] weird I don't
think I would do that I'm just humans
are [__] we I'm not a joiner the
human psychology is [__] very flawed
and I'm actually always been really glad
that I'm not a joiner yeah I think it I
think it's a lot safer I was [__]
telling you early on be careful of any
kind of
ideology especially any kind of or
anybody that tells you that like I said
that's how people fall into Cults and
stuff like that anybody that tells you
hey I know about you I can make your
life better and stuff like that don't
ever ever ever ever ever I'll show you
the real way to live they don't know
they don't know you and this is kind of
like like I said that's why I'm glad
that I'm kind of a misanthrope and uh
and I'm not a joiner because the second
somebody says hey I know what your
problem is and I can solve your problem
just like no you cannot because you are
not me you know what I mean you don't
know [__] about [__] you don't sh you
don't know [__] about meor says the same
thing going on right now with all this
people politically fighting they [__]
love it yeah it's exactly and it's moral
panics well and I also k each other and
I also don't like another thing that I
think works in my favor I don't like
conflict and I don't like outrage and I
especially don't like manufactured
outrage well it's always manufactured
but that's what I mean so the fact that
I don't have any patience for that um so
a lot of times there people like oh they
you know people um will post like
YouTube videos with these really like uh
provocative titles and it's just kind of
and I'm just kind of like shut up it's
like I don't give a [__] about that it's
just I don't really like that kind of
like trying to stir up outrage it just
irritates me so it's like I don't ever
watch that I don't give it clicks that's
even with outrageous [__] like the Hamas
attack that just happened on Israel that
[__] was outrageous but then Israel's
[__] and and people that are
supporters of Israel are also [__]
making outrageous claims that probably
didn't happen you you don't know you
weren't there well that's what I mean
both sides will [__] play that [__]
you just have to watch because of well I
mean I'm not saying like don't care but
you just have to realize that a lot of
people's especially um you know when
there's money involved if they want you
to click on the article or whatever then
they're going to make everything super
overblown right and they're going to
exaggerate they want to say 50 babies
were beheaded and all these [__]
chicks were sexually assaulted in front
of their dead boyfriend but and that
they have it on video but I go on
forchan and they say well we can't find
these videos they would [__] post
them if they had
them yeah it was bad nobody's going to
say that I mean and it's and it's but it
wasn't as bad as [__] their claiming
if the if the video EV EV evidence is
there I'd see it you know then they go
okay yeah and I saw some video evidence
of the girl in the back the girl from
the party in the back of the vehicle saw
all that but I have a different
explanation about what happened to her U
not saying that they're the good guys
I'm just saying
that they're trying to put the [__] on
11 well you know everybody's trying to
do that and like I said I get I get it
because it's even with like innocuous
[__] yeah um you know whe it's just like
a movie that comes out everybody has to
like [__] cry about something that
was in the movie or something like that
everything has to be ramped up because
there's so much competition for eyeballs
right so like everybody has to turn
everything up to like the highest level
possible to get attention and then when
you put militaries and governments
involved they [__] I so everything is
like that oh they got their budgets they
need to fulfill and like I said it's not
like bad [__] doesn't happen it does it
but you have to one kind of look at
things one with some nuance and two kind
of step back and say well in whose
benefit is it um for them to say this or
to say this is this really what happened
is it a little bit exaggerated and like
I said no one's saying that like [__]
isn't bad yeah like a particular thing
that happens well this is kind of what
we were saying before about I think when
we did the show about this just is kind
of random but like when when we did the
show about like HH Holmes for example
yeah yeah and like all the stuff that
came out of but murder Council and all
this other kind of stuff and we kind of
tried to argue on that show I said we're
not I'm not saying that he's not a
serial killer I'm not saying that he did
horrible [__] I'm just saying that some
of the claims that were made not yeah
true right uh that they exaggerated
after to sell newspapers which is the
same thing they do nowadays so it's like
so I'm not trying to say that HH Holmes
was a good dude obviously he was a
monster but I'm just saying that a lot
of the stuff that people attribute to
him didn't really happen he did bad
enough [__] as it was you don't need to
exaggerate it a lot of the [__] that
they do now doesn't have anything to do
with selling newspapers the newspapers
don't and and papers don't need to make
money because they're based here in the
United States they're basically
mercenary operations for [__] the
government that CIA that happened during
the Patriot Act so they don't really
actually need to make money but what
they're doing with the [__] material
is that they're trying to justify
government policy so they can make
contracts it always boils down to money
they want to make big defense contracts
everybody
does so they're of course they're going
to Hype up everything they're going to
turn that seven up to an 11 well like
said that's another thing that I think
works in my favor is that I don't like
hype and I don't like manufactured
conflict and I don't like outrage I
don't like any of that kind of stuff
probably maybe it helps because I took
like journalism classes and stuff like
that so it's just kind of like and I'm
really into language cuz I'm a writer so
I know how use of certain words can make
people feel a certain way and it's like
let's use this word or this phrase
instead of that word in this phrasing
and it can sound kind of different you
know what I mean so I don't know I I
really kind of like come at things from
a
very
uh kind of a chill perspective because
I'm just kind of I'm kind of like
looking at this from a like a Spock like
Viewpoint being like mine is very
military Viewpoint you got to show me or
I won't believe it and I know the
business yeah [__] the Hamas attack
it was a brilliant raid Delta Force
Level some of the the inventiveness was
[__] great land see an air attack
very well executed I saw him [__]
killing people saw him [__] taking
prisoners so I'm taking female prisoners
but the some of the claims that Israel
is saying I haven't seen the video
evidence that they say they have but it
hasn't it hasn't and like you said
you're not saying that it didn't happen
oh it happen it's just that it's not as
they're not showing us all the [__] that
they claim that they have that is even
worse I don't think it's there if they
had it they would have showed
it you know what I mean they would they
would have promoted that so so there's
some hype involved they took captives
though that's you know well like I said
there's hype involved in pretty much
everything because it's it's hard to
there's so much like I said competition
with you know things that are you know
competing for your attention you're
competing for your eyeballs that it's
like they really have to Hype everything
up to like the [__] Stratosphere to
get anybody to like even look at it so
obviously they're going to pile [__] on
yeah but that I mean you know but like I
said that doesn't mean that bad [__]
doesn't happen it does but it's just
kind of like you know they're it's in
their interest to pile [__] on even if
it didn't happen or to like exaggerate
it a little bit but some things aren't
exaggerated right you just have to like
take everything out a case by casee
basis Tyler says off topic but did you
talk about the deli murders we have not
but I think that it was in it's on my
list though but we haven't got around to
it yet possible Odin sacrifice probably
[__] but an interesting story yeah
that's another one that I wanted to do
uh Victor says I definitely want to
adopt a kid or two in the next couple
years yeah like I said I mean some
people like love kids most people love
kids um I don't personally but um you
know that's just me and I'm kind of a
weirdo like that uh Tammy said Tammy
said my daughter has said she never
wants kids she has fur babies yeah I
mean honestly like I said I was young
when I decided I'm like nah and my mom
kept telling me you're going to change
your mind you're going to change but I
never did I never did and I'm 51 now
it's too late so you know what I mean
that ship is sailed but uh yeah but we
have cats and
that's that's far that's way enough for
me trust me I worry enough about about
our little babies that I can't imagine
what having human children were like I
me although I don't know I kind of
consider the cats kind of like human
children they're not as much of a pain
in the ass as human children that's for
sure but they are a little bit of a pain
in the ass but I love them anyway uh
Tammy says is there a dick Ripper if not
maybe I'll invent one you know what's
weird I'm not saying that there wasn't
because that definitely sounds like
something some [__] back then
would have invented right but it's
interesting that the breast Ripper is
one that always comes up it's like hey
let's tear your titties off which some
Sero Killers have done as well I will
note but other than the whole like let's
cut off the dude's dick and you know
cook it and then feed it to him like
I've heard about that happening which
isn't a device necessarily but it was
just kind of like a method that was done
a few times but I don't know if they had
a purpose-built
device for ripping penises off which is
really
interesting I'm not saying that they
didn't have one I'm just saying that if
they did it's not super common I just
find that very fascinating that they
have a breast Ripper but not a dick
Ripper oh well because he didn't want
that to happen to them they didn't think
of that that's what I'm seeing so it's
like it's men coming up with the [__]
and they're just like yeah no
oh dick River not what we don't have
that we're not we're not making that
we're not making that no that's
ungodly we'll rip this bitch's titties
off though for
sure this video is so demonetized it
demonetizes a [__] go ahead go
ahead and hit us with some of the
[__] Super Chat super thanks people
cuz all our [__] as hardcore as we get
we never make any money well you know
what's crazy like almost all of our
shit's demonetized except for like
innocuous [__] like our Wolf Man review
but we remember when we did that show
about the serial killer uh Tony dasta
the other day uh yeah like a couple
weeks ago that was not demonetized I
wonder what for whatever reason even
though usually the True Crime ones are
like the first things to get to and then
we got the Meg Meg 2 review taken down
well that was for copyright but I got it
put back up cuz I bitched yeah I was
like you guys are high what the
[__] but um I was like the two was
pretty good yeah I liked it yeah yeah it
was all right it was just like a big
dumb shark movie big dumb I want to I
want to own one and two on Blu-ray you
going to get it on the little Jason STM
movie starring Jason St as Jason
ston would you go gay for Jason STM no
he's too straight he's too straight too
straight I respect him who would you go
gay
for nobody thank you Victor here here
have some money vict Victor G us some
money that's right I just thought that
was really weird because I was looking
at all the ones I was like demonetized
demonetized but then the Tony dasta one
like I said that's about a serial killer
and there was [__] up there was all
kind of rape and [__] like that that was
fine yeah for whatever Reas it doesn't
make any sense we mostly do the show we
mostly do the shows for the patrons the
patrons are the one to [__] actually
pay us [__] well and we're and we
like do hard no times are hard nobody's
got [__] extra money you know what I
mean it's it's me and Jenny are pimping
each other out on [__] stream mate
making porn and [__] hey at least we're
both doing but at least at least we like
it
yeah man I got beat the crap out of the
other day yeah she's still healing up
I'm still healing up from that that was
because she fell down well yeah that
wasn't anything to do with streaming
that was because I well when you were
changing my nipple piercing and I
fainted yeah I fell funny I guess and I
pulled a tendon or pulled a muscle or
something that write like my rib cage
like on this side and I have not been
able to like [__] move for like three
days so I've been blasting her with all
kinds of steroids trying to get her heal
up and I got like ice packs I'm like
laying there with ice packs going ah
like I can't move around but like yeah
we did streamate the other day and
[__] her up again well yeah because
it's for some it was Monday right yeah
we made we came on like on Monday made
like 50 bucks in a half hour yeah but
like people just came on and said hey do
this do that the other thing and then
and most of it was [__] like hey like
put your dick in her mouth and choke her
and hey sit on her face and smother her
and I was just going like really dude
had her sit on my face till I was
smothered too D well yeah we did that
the other day we we play AC but then you
yeah but then like other day like you
had to sit on my face and like smother
me and also you like got weird dudes out
there they got money though and I was
and I was just kind of like and then
there was like some other stuff to you
they wanted me to like you're sticking
Stu on my butt so so it was that that
didn't happen though what he wanted that
it didn't happen for for remember it did
happen okay I guess it did yeah yeah
yeah remember remember the thing yeah
okay yeah yeah I remember cuz I was just
kind I wasn't really ready for it and I
was just kind of like I remember I
remember now I remember now I think the
dude was into it though cuz he's like oh
she didn't want it to happen yeah yeah
hopefully we got some new
fans oh my God yeah it was just kind of
like yeah
it was a thing we got to update the
videos on [__] uh mini vids too yeah
cuz you don't You' changed so much she's
changed so quickly yeah I've lost like
30 lbs 30 lounds in a month she looks
totally different yeah that's I I do
like my my actual like body shape looks
completely different which is to
different yeah American Military 100
says Jenny have you guys done or
consider doing an episode on the Nazi
era Berlin blackout Strangler aka the
sbond murderer sounds good that yeah
that was another one oh wait a minute
sounds good we did a one well I kind of
feel like a long time ago I have to I
have to go look cuz we've done like so
many shows I thought we did a show about
two blackout
era serial killers and I thought we
mentioned it on there but I don't
remember so I'd have to go back long
long time ago yeah cuz there were two of
them I think we did like two of them
yeah may not and that might have been
one of them but I'll go back and check
because hey Pooky got Pooky fat ass up
here what you doing SE don't call her
that I love you she's round you just a
round ball with feet she's like that's
okay [__] it I'm going yeah she's mad F
she's mad at you Daddy nah she ain't
yeah dtis Sama said YouTube is so weird
yeah I don't I mean there's no human
behind that because like I said we've
had serial killer videos that are
totally fine for ads like totally
monetized and then we've done like movie
reviews where we mentioned nothing
controversial and that was demonetized
for some reason I don't get it it
doesn't make any sense YouTube is smart
tarded well I'm
smarted and I'm offended by the fact
that you would compare is
[__] case you weren't here before
that was the name that I came that was
the smarted that was the word that I
came up with to describe got a lot of
smart arted people around I'm kind of
like I'm I own it though yeah you're not
you're not one of the bad ones though
you're a good smart tarted I'm a good
smart tarted yeah they got bad people
that are smart Ted well no well the
reason that I coined that term if if I
did is that she running the tree Libs
that's that's start that's what I mean
it's just kind of like I like I consider
myself a very intelligent person but
then I will like straight up walk into a
wall you know what I mean cuz I'm just
I'm clumsy I'm just really Clum and I'm
not real um you're getting better though
yeah like you know I can't do [__] with
my I'm just like you know what I mean
like I can't I'm like that you know what
I mean exctly Grands isn't here but if
you were in acting school me and grur
get some drama training you did do some
ballet but drama training would would
have helped you out a lot probably I
thought about doing it yeah but um drama
training I liked all my dance classes I
took I took ballet I took we had time I
tap I took acrobatics I took Jazz I took
all that [__] if we had time I'd send
you to a local drama school but you have
time it might be fine but yeah I don't
have the time or the money no but um but
yeah it probably would help yeah but
yeah or send you to stripper
school dance that'd probably be good I
have thought about taking like pole
dancing classes yeah they stri school
they got stripper schools around here
yeah well like I said they have a whole
like they have pole dancing you can do
pole dancing
classes I don't know where they are
around here it's probably like in I'm
sure there's one around here I can look
her up well it'd be in Orlando which
would be kind of far but yeah but yeah
so well you go to a dance studio those
Studios know that I know they know all
that stuff probably a certain night I
used to do ads for that [__] I've been
thinking about [__] they got a Lo
they got two MMA [__] schools here
I've been thinking about going to MMA
school that would be fun get my combat
prowess back up because I never learned
[__] any
MMA that'd be badass they got they you
would like you would fun you would have
oh yeah good them dudes and start
fighting
playing training how to fight put the
holes get get a better ground game yeah
you know what I mean [__] now that
I'm [__] on [__] so much gear and
Jack I [__] have a good time doing it
yeah yeah Victor says got one here Jenny
you could tell everyone you're 35 and no
one would question question yeah thank
you very much yeah no [__] we go out
and people don't we were at the club
[__] last week and [__] that
20-year-old girl didn't believe that you
were 51 no yeah people on streamate
never believe me either no because they
say well on streamate you put your age
so I just put my age because it's my
account yeah and so sometimes people
because it's a couple's account people
will come on and go which one of you is
51 yeah and I'm like I'm 51 he's 54 yeah
and then he'll and then he'll like even
bring the camera I'm like don't get too
close while people are [__] no no you
you still pass you think even that CL
yeah I know yeah okay you don't you
don't look old I mean I don't think so
but I don't really know plus I'm kind of
blind so I'd say you're late 30s early
40s yeah see that's what I thought I
said I could probably pass for like late
30s yeah maybe but you
know which like I said 35 I'll take it
I'll take it and I think in about a year
your [__] body's gonna be [__]
slamming
you keep up with that training regimen
that we're doing yeah doing all this
stuff it's I gotta get over this [__]
injury man yeah although it's good now
but that might be because I'm kind of
drunk and I took painkillers yeah so I'm
kind of hoping that it'll be better
because I haven't we were going to
stream today and I was just kind of like
I was trying all the dresses on from uh
that we got from team and I'm like
trying to put the dress on I'm like ah
like I can barely move and he's just
like probably we shouldn't stream today
because you can barely move yeah it's
better than it was I'm just hoping that
that's all it is that it's just a pulled
muscle and it's not some other [__]
something else pulled muscle it's got to
be I can't think of anything else it
could appeared out of nowhere that's
going away yeah and like I said it
happened after I fainted yeah and fell
to the floor like a sack of potatoes um
dentos Sama says being 24 with a baby
face I'm always mistaken for 16 you'll
appreciate that more when you get older
yeah so sies you don't look 40s or
50s well that's good I'd say late 30s
early 40s that's see that's what I would
say yeah because I think I remember
pictures of me like when I met you and I
think I met you and I was about 38
because that was about when I divorced
yeah and um and I think I look pretty
much the
same s or similar as I looked then as
far as age goes you know what I mean I
don't think I look that much older than
I looked when I was 38 which was a while
ago Lloyd didn't know how old I was when
I told him he he was like really the
white girl whisper white girl Whisperer
yeah he thought I was he thought I was
in my 40s early 40s like a [__] real
good early 40s like I said we know some
people in their 50s that look real young
and we know some people in their 50s
that look [__] up a lot older than us
yeah so it's just kind of a I don't want
to say it's a crap sh got a friend
that's a couple years younger than me
who looks like [__] who looks like an
old man looks like an old man looks like
in his 70s yeah
60s yeah just he won't do the right
thing he tried to but he couldn't stick
with it I think if yeah I think anybody
I think if anybody put you and him
together everybody would think that he
was significantly older than you yeah no
he's younger than me but he's not yeah
he went on test for a while and [__]
made some advances he was going to the
gym and everything but he could stick
with it not enough
willpower and I'm like well he's got
money and he's got [__] he's got call
girls so what does he need what what
does he need to look good for he pays
them yeah yeah that's true it's probably
like too much eff that's his thinking
yeah I get it I was like dude if you
look good you wouldn't have to pay him
he's yeah that's okay I'll just pay him
it's
easier I mean I get it assho I get it
you know what I mean all right so um so
the next one here's one that everybody
brought up earlier so we're finally
getting to talking about the pair of
Anguish also called the choke Paar or
the mouth pee sometimes p e not p as in
urine like PE no P EA yeah like a you
know like a musy
PE so I have a picture of this so let's
see what this looks like where is it
at uh where did it go where did it go
okay maybe I don't you don't have the
picture of that yeah I thought I did
there it is there it is yeah that's the
one I remember it's got a screw in there
and everything like I said it kind of
reminds look how well made that is it
kind of reminds me of going to the
gynecologist although the one from the
gynecologist has like a rod in the
middle and then it has like they're not
as pointy as that about when is that
from this one I don't know when this one
in particular is from look how well made
that is I know it's nice right well see
that's another thing that kind of blows
my mind is like people actually like
Artisans yeah made this [__] that's got
threads on it man see the
thread look at it it's got Precision
threads on it and look they made it with
like this [__] what is what is this
[__] over here like little like it's the
knob that you turn little no no no no I
meant like what like are the little
centur or whatever the [__] that is over
there I don't really see it little
everything's decorated right cuz if
you're going to make it you might as
well make that [__] fancy as
[__] just well that cuz like can you
imagine here comes the grand Inquisitor
yeah over here being like I'm about to
stick this right in your anus yeah it's
fancy isn't it fancy yeah just and he's
like doing it like like [__] Vana
White on the [__] yeah right just fancy
as [__] or Price is Right or something
like like just showing it to you so yeah
pair of Anguish like I said yeah so this
thing yeah as you can see from the
picture this was a thing they would
alternately they would stick it in your
vagina if you're a woman or up your ass
yeah or in your mouth depending on what
you had done and they didn't wash that
[__] either well like I said just like
we were talking about the an pyramid
earlier they didn't have sanitation it's
like hey that also has Gary's butt juice
on it and this is also going right up
your butt so have fun with all the
bacteria yeah that's pretty so like I
said even if it didn't kill it was bad
enough that it just kind of like hurt
you and it's like and then like later
you're like oh my God now I have [__]
whatever whatever disease now I have the
plague yeah so so it's like man the
Middle Ages really sucked like tamy went
damn yeah yeah so this was the one yeah
I kind of feel like this is the one look
like it was made out of brass too it did
yeah I mean they weren't all like that
one of the things that impressed me
though that looked very modern the
threads were [__] Precision cut
threads so they must have had some kind
of tool that they put down that shaft
and pulled it to get the threads that
way that wasn't hand done it was done
with a machine yeah so they had a thread
things that's a [__] and the fact
that they put so much time and
Engineering made it all decorative and
[__] into that some dude made a [__] ton
of money making it just to see that kind
of [__] like that's the kind of [__]
that keeps yeah they they weren't into
[__] utilitarianism I mean their guns
were like that too later on just [__]
totally decorated you
know I mean damine barrels and [__] so
what they would
do if you were a heretic you'd said some
[__] about the church or something like
that then they would stick it in your
mouth like down your throat and then you
were talking crank it open and then yeah
like break all your teeth and stuff if
you were a woman and you were accused of
Witchcraft yeah then they would stick it
in your vagina yeah and open the [__] up
like I said kind of looks like a
speculum like you'd have it the fo but
much much worse cuz that's bad enough
for open up let that [__] air out but I
guess well no I mean I know you've never
a gynecologist but they do have a thing
the speculum it's like a metal rod about
probably that big around yeah with like
kind of two spoon like things yeah and
so they just stick it up in there and
then they wrench it so they can stick
their whole hand in there damn the whole
hand pretty much yeah because they want
to feel around they want to make sure
you don't have any cancer or they're
yeah you know they got to get um and
they got to do paps Mir and all that
kind of stuff yeah so it has to be big
enough for them to get the [__] in there
um you know they Lube it and everything
it's not they're not rude how long does
it take take to expand that [__] out no
not long um it's not
comfortable um I trying to fist somebody
it's like a [__] chore right but okay
here's the thing what they do and maybe
this is TMI for dudes yeah but um well
hey we have to go through this every
year okay so it's just you go in the
office every guy of College's office
I've ever been to and I've been to a lot
they all have the table you got you got
to lay it on the table yeah with the
with paper on it whatnot put your legs
up in the stups every single one of them
has and this always makes me laugh every
single time they have like a land like a
beautiful landscape picture pinned up on
the ceiling so when you're laid down
picture Bob Ross up
there oh my God that would be funny like
Bob Ross like happy little trees that'd
be hilarious no everyone I've ever been
to it's usually just like a picture of
like a real Serene looking like
landscape and it's like every time I see
that it just makes me laugh but it's
just like every single one of them has
that pinned up on the ceiling so you're
watching that cuz it's like hey feel
better about somebody like sticking
their hand or sticking this device up
your cooch so yeah this person you don't
really know all that well so yeah so
they put it it's just it's not huge it's
just it's not even as big as like a big
dildo it's just kind of like it's dildo
size but not like the scary like stunt
one all these men are getting education
right now no I'm well I'm just saying
this is what you do so it's metal they
they Lube it all up with Vaseline or an
equivalent and and then they put it in
there and then you know and it just kind
of goes and it's
just um it's not a great sensation yeah
M up but you know it's just kind of like
yeah and then like all I've always gone
to um female gynecologist well I went to
one male gynecologist but I didn't
really I'm like I'm not comfortable with
that he was nice I'm not but he wasn't a
creep or weird or anything but I was I'm
more comfortable with women gynecologist
plus it's it's more comfortable telling
them [__] about your period and stuff
when they've had a period too dudes
don't know what you're talking about so
you know what I mean so um so yeah so
I've always been more comfortable with
women doctors but yeah so they do that
and then they just put and then they
just stick their they Lube their hand up
too and it's got a glove and everything
and they just stick their whole hand in
there yeah feeling and they feel around
tamy says like yeah it's like you're on
vacation looking up at
that every single time and it just it
always makes me laugh and I'm always
just kind of like laying I'm like I
wonder what kind of picture they got up
there oh look at that nice that's nice
yeah you trying to little trying to lose
yourself
upct over here with the cows and the
[__] the [__] milk made it's
almost always well there's not usually
any people in it it's almost always like
a landscape like a waterfall or like a
flowery field or something big old
[__] it's always something like that
big old mountain yeah it's you it's
almost always it's like a Bob Ross
painting pretty much no people or
nothing so it's like that I don't know
why that makes me laugh so much but it
does but yeah so then they feel like I
said said they have to feel around there
cuz they have to feel around for you
know cancerous lumps and stuff and then
they also have like a
long uh like a long Q-tip situation yeah
because they have to take out a bunch of
stuff so they you know pass samples
right they have to take a sample so yeah
it's um you know what's it got to do
with the pear the pair because the pear
also goes up your vagina and it because
it reminded me of a speculum it's it's a
similar concept yeah um because it's
spreading out your [__] but um but this
one is like a lot more let's call it the
Sinister would it be spreading out more
than
that speculum yes well yeah because the
speculum isn't all four sides and it's
not pointy obviously because it's not
made to torture you it's just made to
open you up so they can get in there and
like look in there and feel around in
there and stuff so this one is kind of
like
pointy and it's all four sides like
leaves yeah so they and you can open it
open it open it like all the way out
right yeah you know what I mean so it's
kind of meant to like tear your [__] up
did it kill the women you think
sometimes um sometimes it did uh you
know and also if you were a dude and you
were accused of sodomy like I said at
homosexuality then they would stick it
up your ass in yeah but they could open
that [__] up damn yeah so Victor would
have no problem you he'd say open that
[__] wide up wide open it's all right
that's what I mean yeah you're not not
even going to fase
me
like I said like that girl with the
[__] with kind of Cu yeah that's what
I mean I'm kind of curious just like
don't make them go back there like
forever like really go through with Mod
porn star would show up but I wonder
what would happen she like yeah bring it
yeah I ain't nothing yeah they stick it
up and they're like holy [__] this woman
must be a witch we should cut we should
cut her head off like that's probably
what they would think that's good you
got a bigger one she's like oh that's
kind of that kind of tickle yeah what
what else you got and they be like what
the [__] yeah the devil told me to tell
you to get a bigger
one that [__] that shit's
nothing right that's what I mean if you
talk back I'm going to jump up and land
on your head first and just go all
y like a [__] I'll put your entire
octopus [__] like an octopus
I'll digest your ass suppository Style
imagine it oh my God now I want to write
a movie yeah where a modern porn star
just goes back to the Inquisition age
yeah and just goes to like all these
[__] who are like torturing
women and stuff and just like engulfs
their head in their ass and just
Smothers them like that it dig wouldn't
that be awesome I would totally I'm
going to I'm I'm be hot kiky Joe I'm in
starting to I'm starting to Kickstart be
a porn star Nam hot kiky Joe she goes
back and [__] all these dudes up I'm
starting a Kickstarter yeah I mean
there's got to be other weirdos out
there that want to see that movie too
like all those people get killed like
that but yeah so um much like the Iron
Maiden however there have been some
Scholars that have disputed the
existence well it's not I mean obviously
they existed but they didn't really know
if this uh pair of
Anguish was actually used for what
people thought it was used for you know
what I mean um there are some examples
of them like that are definitely from
the early modern period um but the thing
about it is that they're not really sure
if this was a torture device or if it
was used for something else you know
what I mean so there's kind of like a
little bit of controversy about whether
this one was used for what people
believed it was used for although I have
seen more accounts of this from that
time period than I have the Iron Maiden
you know what I mean like if it is kind
of suspicious that it's so well made
true it looks I mean that might have
just been a I mean that's just one
particular example of it I mean there
might have been some other really maybe
that was a reproduction that could be
too that could be too
so that could be too might have been
some rich guy wanted a reproduction back
in like the Iron Maiden I feel like
given all of the other medieval torture
devices that we know
existed in the Middle Ages this doesn't
really seem that [__] up I mean this
seems right along the lines of the [__]
they were inventing yeah somebody
totally wouldn't invented this hey I'm
going to have this thing that you can
stick up somebody's cooch or their ass
and open their mouth and opens up and
[__] opens up and [__] them up I mean
that's seems like a pretty simple
concept you want to be a hoe [__] go
put this in there want to be a homo
we'll put this in there you want to talk
[__] we'll put it in there yeah I mean
it seems so this one doesn't seem child
it's some child it's some childish [__]
they would probably come up with some
childish [__] I mean I mean the Iron
Maiden I get the concept behind it it's
a pretty it's a fairly simple concept
but it does seem kind of complicated for
what it is this is pretty simple and
seems like something that somebody back
then would have invented yeah so I I
find this less impla less implausible
than maybe the Iron Maiden was I'm just
saying okay um also here's this other
one uh here's another one much like the
breast Ripper this one is this is pretty
self-explanatory and this this one is
called just the head Crusher the head
Crusher the head Crusher uh which which
we got here that's that's that right
there see okay how do we do this you can
either put I see J you either put your
head yeah Jesus's head is in there you
can either put it in sideways like that
or you can put it in up and down yeah so
you can either Crush one side you can
crush it sideways or top to bottom right
right right okay so yeah I mean you can
imagine how this how this works it's a
very simple machine it is very simple
like I said that's that's why I kind of
feel like the pair was probably it
almost looks like something out of a
prin printing press really it does and
maybe that's where they got the idea
they got the idea yeah that's probably
where they got the at the idea now
normally I think this one kind of looks
like well at least the head crushing
part looks like it's made of wood but
maybe not like the other the screw part
looks like it's made of metal but I
think most of the time they were made of
metal the other examples of it I've seen
were made of metal probably made of
brass um yeah so basically as you can
see from the photo you put your head in
there either sideways like Jesus was
there or up in down and then they would
just slowly twist this little handle up
there until it like crushed sh smooshed
your head yeah like including like
crushing your teeth together like your
mandibles together all your facial bones
um yeah so it would crush your head like
on Kids in the Hall I'm crushing your
head it it was that wonder if they
actually used that oh I'm sure until it
crushed somebody's head or if it was a
if it was more of a
threat do we do they
have proof that people were killed that
way as as far as I know now this one
there's no controversy about whether
this [__] existed existed because yeah
okay also uh at least according to
Wikipedia it says some versions of This
Not That version that I just showed you
but some versions of it had a little
receptacle in the front that would catch
the person's eyes when they popped out
which is a nice feature yeah but your
eyes wouldn't pop out I'm just saying
they're like well in well they were
hoping probably they're like o I hope
the eyes pop out on this one yeah cuz
they were [__] up back then you know
what I'm saying yeah it was probably
that situation sounds very
psychological this is where your eyes
yeah that yeah that might have been
another yeah that might have been
another aspect to it it's like well we
don't think the eyeballs are really
going to pop out but we're going to tell
them that their eyeballs are going to
pop out yeah and this is where we're
going to catch them you're right yeah
then we're going to make him like look
back at like you're crushing somebody's
head and you don't want those eyes to
fall on the ground we want to catch them
you know F think about it like I said we
like we'll take them on the optic nerves
and we'll just turn them around so you
can see yourself see each other so one
eye can look at the other eye and then
look at the other eye oh my God I mean
seriously yeah so uh so yeah there was
that also um these white folks are
[__] crazy they are I'm telling you
right now um yeah they said that also
sometimes the torturers because of
course they couldn't just like squish
your head yeah like sometimes they kind
of half squish your head and then they
take a hammer and then like be like he
Bam Bam Bam like on the [__] cuz you
know yeah they have to kind of like [__]
with you like that what is wrong with
these people they're
torturers what the [__] is wrong with
you but skulls all busted up and then
they got to come in with a little
ballpen hammer and [__] they just got
to like [__] make it feel worse Guild
the Lily yeah I guess like in a [__]
up kind of way yeah cuz the skull is all
crashed yeah so you're going to feel it
all you're going to feel all those
[__] bones rubbing together with a
little imp oh no it's like oh you're all
[__] yeah um also had another one and
this is one that I remember reading
about when I was a kid probably when I
was too young to read about this stuff
uh
strappado uh this is when they basically
take you they tie your hands behind your
back and then they put a rope around
both your wrists and Pull the Rope up by
a pulley yeah so your arm so they
basically to pull you up until your
shoulders dislocate yeah yeah I've seen
and then they leave you hanging there
yeah for and you know honestly like also
for extra pain they would put weights on
your ankles as well I've seen paintings
of it they were doing I think I have a
picture they were doing lots of that in
the French Revolution yeah yeah yeah
there we go there we go somebody she
don't well yeah she does have a weight
on her ankles I've seen even better
paintings of it but yeah that's just
like a wood C but yeah they just that's
how they do it they put your hands and
that dislocates your shoulders oh and
look they're burning somebody's feet
there too in this in this little yeah
look they got like little little F
they're likeing and this dude's like oh
and that Dead's like ah they got all
these scholarly [__] judging it
taking wrri down what they're saying 9.5
they like give them like olympic scores
and [__] like that real good screaming
yeah yeah but this I don't know why this
one always kind of like [__] me up
because I don't know it just seems like
it's not it seems not as bad as the
other stuff like having your intestines
pulled out or having stuff like a wooden
pyramid shoved up your ass or anything
like that but it's just kind of like
there's something about the physicality
of being pulled up by your wrist and
having your shoulders dislocated well
that's something that's M you can
maintain that you can keep a person in
that position for a long time that's not
going to kill you no no that's the hell
of it and I think this is why this one
was used a lot was because you know you
weren't severing any limbs you weren't
like they weren't bleeding nothing like
that so you could leave them hanging
like that for a long time yeah and they
could survive it and it was really
painful but yeah it wouldn't kill you
necessarily so it's like that was
probably I think this was one that they
used quite a lot yeah um although I
think it would kill you if they left you
up there long enough but probably you
could probably you could probably be up
there 24 hours probably I would imagine
yeah I mean if they put weights on you
probably less but I don't know I kind of
it would depend on the person I guess
you could breathe yeah it would depend
on the person I guess because you might
black out like if the pain was too much
that particular one was used in the
French Revolution a
lot it he a dude up like that with
weight on his feet guys that come with
bayonets rifle bayonets and poke them
every now and then keep them from keep
them in agony I don't know I can't
imagine trying to get some kind of
confession that they were
anti-revolutionary or something yeah I
can't imagine getting any kind of like
enjoyment out of watching other people
suffer like yeah oh yeah well like I
said ideology man ideology is the
[__] killer CU When the French were
doing that it wasn't didn't have
anything to do with religion it was
[__]
politics
politics and [__] whether or not you
were with the people or or you were
[__] you know a royalist that kind of
thing so Victor said and they would they
would [__] accuse anybody of anything
well sure you know Victor said I gave a
suppository on my last
shift Victor gave a suppository on his
last shift did he yeah who'd he give it
to well a patient i' imagine okay no
just a random a random person on the
street hey can I stick a depository put
that [__] up on his finger little like
that is what What's That Brand it's a
fleet right Fleet suppository that's the
only brand of suppository I know got all
these gay
nurses I was telling you uh are are you
scared that like somebody like they're
going get off have a gay nurse rather
have a gay nurse probably yeah well that
you know that that's what my boy my boy
[__] Toby yeah that leather daddy I
was telling you about he's a nurse a
friend of ours yeah like a leather daddy
d dadd he's also a nurse he's a nurse
yeah I imagine he yeah well I imagine
he's probably really good at it yeah
he's a very nice compassionate person
MH and he seems to he's doing something
bad to you well yeah
but no he's a good dude yeah he's a
really good dude he's calling me down
there to [__] put his [__] gym set
together yeah cuz he painted his he's
got his own [__] gym he's putting
together in his house he painted the
walls and everything he's going to have
[__] and [__] sound system and
[__] I said you're going on test right
you're going to go on gear I'm I got to
do more research on man stop that [__]
well he's older than we are he's older
than me man you can be on [__] test
he looks good though he looks pretty
good he's like yeah but I'm I'm I'm good
and I was like nah I do a blood test on
you man [__] you're good but for your
age you know that [__] needs to
be on test you'll [__] he'll [__]
buff right back out like he was cuz see
I've known him for [__] 15 years yeah
we know a long time not do a long time
way he looked in his [__] late 30s
man a big difference well not a big
difference just difference he aged well
but he he needs he needs the same
treatment I'm on you know he'd be all
right he's just scared you know I don't
know why he didn't research it he hasn't
researched it yet he doesn't know about
hormone HRT he doesn't know about it
you'll be all right though yeah I'm not
worried about it [__] we're going to
see his ass [__] Friday probably yeah
Friday night yeah he's probably going to
be there Friday night I imagine yeah
it's the Friday the 13th momento myy
yeah that'll be fun all right so last
one I want to talk about is one that
somebody brought up earlier and one that
you have uh you know a great deal about
Good Old Brazen bull yeah or the bronze
bowl that was [__] Greek though yeah
although they did use it in the Middle
Ages they did okay they did um so yeah
it was as the name implies it was a
sculpture essentially usually made of
bronze that looked like a bowl lifesize
and it had a little door in the
side um now the person that was going to
be put in here they would cut their
tongue
out for you know shits and giggles and
then they would put the person inside
the bowl shut the door and then they
would light fires all underneath it and
basically roast you alive now one of the
features that was added later um was
that the sounds that the person would
make inside they would they did like all
this acoustical stuff where it would
make it sound like a real bull like all
the people like screaming and struggling
in there they would make it sound like
what a real bull would sound like like
that that was one of the improvements
that they made on it that's what that's
not what I actually heard
but there are some Greek stories about
this in this about like later on yeah
the Greek story is about this I don't
remember the king's name that had the
[__] commissioned but he commissioned it
FIS what was his name FIS agrigentum
okay that's his name I don't know if he
necessarily I don't know if he
specifically asked for this but like the
legend goes he asked his mad scientist
to come yeah that like the dude that
invented it his name was perillus perill
supposedly invented it for this for this
King Tyrant like this King actually the
king I heard was actually kind of a good
guy well no because he ended up in that
[__] later like his own people put him
in there in the bowl really that
particular guy cuz I thought the mad
scientist that made it what was was the
guy that made it no the king ended up in
there he ended up in it okay yes
probably a [__] Legend This maybe
yeah I don't know this [__] is probably
a legend a lot of the Greek [__] is
Legend okay it probably didn't
happen that particular kid wanted uh
some kind of a [__] method of
executing his enemies he wanted to be as
bad as he
possibly that's pretty bad it could be
that's pretty bad so he had this mad
scientist come up and what was his name
the mad scientist name perill perillis
perillus figured this [__]
parilus and it was a bronze
bull that you could get
in and they could set a fire on it
underneath it and it would it would you
yeah and your screams and your breathing
would go through a [__] tube yeah uh
and and it would make music
basically um kind of like a like a horn
see I heard that they wanted to make it
sound like a real bull because people
thought that was like really I remember
it was it was music okay like like an
organ and uh
so the idea was is that the king could
have his enemies in there roasting alive
and he could have his [__] feast and
his parties with all his guests around
this bull would be there making music
like in the middle like it's like an ice
sculpture like 100 times more [__] up
so you can show how what a badass you
were you know what I mean like there's a
[__] in there bur D enemies
produced to the [__] music it was
like the DJ at your party
okay so they like I said creative so the
mad scientist makes this [__] and his
advis and the King's advisers are like
man this dude's [__] Insidious coming
up with this [__] you you can't let him
live not an evil [__] like that
and evidently he was the scientist that
made it up was a evil you know I think
he did end up in the bull also so the
king but the king did too the king said
DE after it was made he says this
thing's genius and say we're going to
try it out and he's like you get in it
and he's like no no no you get in there
this I'm not so they he put him in it as
and they set the fire
and he was in it for evidently a while
he didn't cut his tongue out or
anything but then uh he decided to take
him out he had mercy and took him out
that was that was the story I although I
don't think I could forgive that I'm say
and the dude came out and then he kind
of laughed it off like it was all just a
joke you know what I mean and [__] he
was like half cooked you know and he
tried to laugh laugh it off yeah good
good good good job King it works you
know that kind of [__] I didn't know
that the king I didn't hear that the
king later on end up he ended up in it
also uh now here's here's the here's the
uh or so The Story
Goes here's the controversy how does
this thing actually work are your hands
and feet touching the bottom of it CU
it's bronze see that's what I I saw one
they have one in St Augustine yeah um I
it's hard to say I mean you can open the
door and look in there like like you can
look inside two arguments they said that
if you're just sitting in this thing
trying to breathe through a tube the the
heat would be conducted right through
that [__] bronze bull Brass Bull I
think it was brass I
think brass or bronze and you would just
[__] die pretty quickly you would
think cuz you're you you'd suffer
[__] second degree burns and third
degree burns
and because you're resting upon that
metal the uh breathing through the tube
would keep you alive longer because
you're breathing air that is ambient
temperature right not air that is from
inside that bull because it would be
heated a lot of people think that if
this thing ever existed it may have just
been a legend but if this thing really
existed in in the early days you
probably didn't touch the bottom of the
bull you were probably suspended up off
the
bottom
on something that your knees and your
hands could rest on on that was kind of
insulated uh so it wasn't flesh to metal
contact and then you had this you had no
choice but to breathe through this solid
[__]
tube coming down because it was too hot
to breathe inside there so you had to
breathe fresh air from
outside and you inhaling and exhaling
caused the
music to happen or it was like a a bull
like whining music whatever it was you
know I'm sure it wasn't music yeah it
was probably a whistle or something like
that you
know if it existed like I said I read
that later they kind of engineered it so
that the breathing would sound more like
an actual bull because people thought
that was more entertaining apparently
yeah maybe cuz like I said these this
was a showpiece like a lot of these
torture things like some of the stuff
was done like in Dungeons and [__] but a
lot of the stuff was done kind of like
in public or you know as a deterrent
yeah um this one in particular was kind
of you know if it existed like I said
they they did say the Greeks had it the
ancient Romans supposed some supposedly
some ancient Christians were martyred in
it well the Greeks claimed they had it
that King had it but um so this one was
very much made to be like a public
spectacle yeah and I feel like uh the
longer it went on the more they tried to
make it more entertaining for the crowd
that would come to see it so there's
evidence that it was actually used in
the medieval period later yeah okay and
it might have been a same situation with
the ninja where it started off as Legend
but then they made it real which is
life well like I said that also happened
with the Iron Maiden which like I said
was seems like it was just like a
fictional creation but kind of based on
some real [__] but then like after the
fictional creation came out like people
were like oh man that's a good idea they
started making them yeah so now they
exist but it's just they might not exist
in the context that you think they exist
I wonder how long you could live in it
before you died what in the Iron Maiden
or in the Brazen bull in the Brazen bull
in the Brass Bull I guess it would
depend on what the temperature of the
fire was probably not a very hot fire
what your fortitude was they probably
didn't put a very big fire underneath
there it's probably slow cooking a bit
well like I said I kind yeah but would
you die of heat exhaustion before what I
mean what would kill you yeah the thing
about it was that lot of these torture
methods were devised to as I said cause
the maximum am amount of pain but like
keep you alive and conscious at the same
time which is kind of like a a delicate
balance I guess if you want to put it
like that yeah so they didn't
necessarily want to kill people they
wanted especially something like the
Brazen bull which like I said if it
existed was made for kind of public
display like look hey we put a
[__] in here we're like slowly
roasting him alive you wanted to keep
that [__] alive as long as
possible
yeah but suffering right same kind of
thing with the Judas cradle or anything
like that you didn't want to kill them
right away you just wanted them to be
alive for a long time but suffering a
lot of pain so I so I don't know I kind
of feel like this was
engineered I don't like I said I guess
it would depend on the fortitude of the
person that you put in there but if you
if the fire wasn't that
hot and if you could still breathe out
of the tube that was coming out of the
bull's mouth you could probably live in
there for quite I'm not saying that you
would want to be alive in there the
problem is if the heat isn't
enough you would just die of dehydration
and heat
exhaustion which you wouldn't think that
they would want that they want you to
die like a slow cooking I mean people
have died in like sweat lodges and
things like and saunas and [__] like
that so it have to be hotter than that
right something you would blister
up yeah you know what I mean but but I
don't know how how long you'd live I
don't know either it might be mostly a
legend and then it probably didn't work
in practice as intended I mean it killed
the
person but it probably didn't last as
long as people wanted it to can you
imagine the [__] meeting where you
invented some like new fancy torture
device and you going and like presenting
it like you got your prototype and [__]
like that and you're just like and here
and here we have Gary that will
demonstrate like get inside there Gary
He's like I don't want to get in there
no get in there Gary Come on it'll be
fine and like so he gets in there that
he closes it sets the fire and [__] like
that Gary starts screaming and [__] and
like the dude like your boss or whatever
sitting back there I like it but can we
make it so like he screams more or you
know what I mean it's like he's given
like [__] pointers and [__] it's just
it's so messed up this whole I'm trying
to remember my memory situation is so
mess I'm trying to remember my memory of
how I was told about the brass Bowl
where they took the B side his back out
and he tried to laugh it off I think the
king put him back in there I think I I
don't I think I can't imagine I think
they put him back I think he put him
back in I can't imagine I don't remember
that they would let him out of that and
then he's just kind of like cool with it
he's just like or he is at least
pretending to long time since I've heard
of it but then I I think I might put it
back in it he like well there was
anything he could do I smell like pork
ribs delicious yeah yeah I had I I don't
remember maybe in the comments section
you guys could drop it in there I have a
really dark sense of humor so it's like
this kind of stuff just it just sets my
mind spinning like all these kind of
like I kind got the feeling that they
pulled him back out and he's like they
laughed it off and the King was like nah
n he's got to go back in
there we can't let him live I'm just
kind of imagining what kind of what kind
of friends would you have like like
Tom's like hey Jen get in this get in
this Brass Ball I'm just going to like a
little light a little fire in it then
I'm like half burned and I'm like I'm
kind of cooked on the side and stuff and
then he lets me out and I'm just like ah
hilarious yeah good job good you're
you're hilarious then he's like no just
get back no you got get
[Laughter]
yeah Victor said it was bronze brass
came about a lot okay yeah the one that
I saw um and it was probably like a
replica but they do have one in the um
St Augustine Torture Museum yeah and I'm
pretty sure that one was brass but that
was like I said that was probably like a
replica they were just showing you how
it worked and you can go over there and
like open the door like they let you
open the bronze was old school medal
yeah that's Greek here Bronze
Age it was soft Danny Rowling said some
say the bull statue in New York is this
bull torture device in secret yeah I've
heard that as well like that one that
they have it's on Wall Street or
something in front of Wall Street yeah
yeah that it's like they they slam
people up in there and then light a fire
underneath sure but but yeah so like I
said they they said some Christians were
mared it as well but I don't really know
if that's true so this is another one
that I don't know it probably existed
was it used for its intended purpose was
it used on a large scale I don't know
know I kind of feel like more stuff like
the rack the wheel the boot that kind of
stuff that was more like simple to Stak
yeah burning people to Stak yeah like I
didn't even mention that because that's
not really a device per se it was more
like execution yeah it was just more
like an execution like I said and they
did that a lot um so I kind of feel like
it was more that kind of stuff if you're
going to do real elaborate stuff like a
Brazen bll I mean that you have to
commit because somebody has to make that
and it's not like nowadays where you
just make it in a factory like out of
plastic or whatever you got to like
Artisans got to make that so I kind of
feel like if you're going to make that
that's going to be somebody
commissioning it for hey I'm going to
have a party where I'm going to burn
some [__] alive if everybody
come see that [__] you know what I mean
a feeling you got to be a scientist when
it comes to the correct temperature
though well that's what I mean there's a
lot of factors that you have to you to
take into consideration and this is
before you had [__] gas powered
stoves you had to know how much wood had
to be on how big kind of wood yeah and
how big the fire had to be to get
maximum duration that's what I'm saying
they and see that's the thing that kind
of like depresses me about it because
look how much thought yeah is put into
that kind of stuff imagine how much
further along we would be now in 2023 if
people back then weren't consumed with
thinking about this kind of [__] well in
the Roman era they were at the cusp of a
[__] industrial revolution had that
[__] happened we would have been on the
Moon yeah then they [__] probably
[__] in like 400 ad cuz we just can't
we just keep shooting ourselves in the
dick why do I why do we do that uh lot
had to do a lot of it has to do with
[__]
greed well yeah the reason why Rome
didn't really Advance is because uh the
main players inside of Rome had a vested
interest in keeping things the same when
it came to how the economy ran that's
another thing and Technology they didn't
need mechanical technology because they
had a [__] vast source of Labor they
they used German
slaves so there was no reason to well
and anytime a new technology comes along
I kind of feel like there's always kind
of like a fear of it well no well yeah
but what it was with them is that
technology is labor saving devices right
they didn't need labor they had plenty
of cheap labor like look a machine was
more expensive than a slave right so
there was we all all these
interchangeable but they had steam power
you know the only thing that they
needed that made money the only
application was to open and close doors
at proper times inside religious temples
to prove that certain gods live because
the religion was a big
business they had they had all the
[__] makings even understood they
understood the principles of mass
production so they had they had
everything that they actually needed for
industrial revolution and had they
figured out steam
locomotion that would have saved them
because they would have been able to
repel Barbarian attacks if they had a
railroad and then they figured out
[__] electricity they had a
telegraph which is not crazy because
it's like that it was the the knowledge
was there was yeah and [__] they could
we were figuring that out in the 1800s
Telegraph and [__] they could have
absolutely they weren't that far from
that back then it could have easily been
to that had they had they need had they
had a labor shortage but they didn't
right so they just ah [__] it we don't
need any Mach you know what they say
necessity is the they didn't have a need
for so if you didn't need it then I
don't even remember he said that but
right that's a very that's a very famous
had that [__] happen the next thing you
know they' have [__] been [__]
with
aircraft internal combustion we been way
ahead yeah and you we'd have been we'd
have been at the Moon by about [__]
300 ad probably yeah which is crazy to
think about but like I said it's not
they'd be putting the damn sqpr [__]
Roman [__] flag on the moon instead
of the American Moon instead of the
American flag somebody make that movie
yeah ancient Romans on the moon ancient
Romans on the moon and 4 walk around
with their [__] sandals and skirts on
yeah hey it proba would looked like that
by then well I know but I'm just saying
that's that's everybody's conception of
it so that's why I said that and if you
made a movie if Asylum made a movie
ancient Romans on the moon um then then
that's when you really get right down to
it the problem with the Roman economy
and it's and and the reason why the
technology didn't Advance is that they
have
slavery slavery is bad for your economy
and it [__] stops [__] technology
because you don't need labor saving
devices yeah because there's all these
interchangeable you got labor humans
that you can treat like and the elite
sat up [__] getting blown and jerked
off by [__] gorgeous slaves what the
[__] do they need labor saving devices
for for they were happy everybody else
was [__] suffering but they didn't
give a [__] about them they their own
[__] of course so and and [__] even
ancient Roman historians tell you that
that it was their problems were that
they had a [__] selfish [__]
ruling class well I kind of feel like
that's the problem throughout
history a most people and this is kind
of sad but most people don't really give
a crap about people that aren like them
or that they don't like know you know
status is the main driver [__] the
elites [__] had high status they give
a [__] about anybody else no of course
why why higher their status that the
high why would they have reason to they
don't need to interact with any of and
the lower the people are the higher
their status the more power they have so
they like it more yeah because they
could just have their pick and choose of
any kind of person that they want to
[__] or kill you you know or they were
making a [__] ton of money so that was a
problem yeah
yeah selfishness yeah it leads to
[__] it's a problem it leads to
[__] regressive
[__] they go backwards instead of
forwards it does yeah and that's I you
won't find any argument for my end Danny
Rowling said Oblivion is a good ass film
it is I agree which one was Oblivion Tom
Cruz oh yeah I like that movie I liked
that as well Tom Cruz meets his clone
yeah and like I said I don't usually
like Tom Cruz but he was actually really
good in that yeah I like Tom I like that
movie quite a bit um the last the true
movie
stars pretty much yeah yeah I mean you
know yeah the Tom Cruz movie starring
Tom Cruz as Tom Cruz I me Tom Cruz the
movie that'll be the next thing yeah
yeah yeah Tom Cruz it be Tom Cruz as Tom
Cruz in a Tom Cruz
movie called Tom Cruz the movie the
movie yeah you know it's going to happen
yeah of course you know you go see a
[__] it's Tom Cruz and it's like 3 hours
long [__] three hours Tom Cruz man
and it's a Scientology recruitment it's
[__] and it's a blockbuster it's a
Blockbusters it's got jets in it and it
makes a billion dollars yeah yeah it's
got jets in it and everything and then
everybody joins Scientology and the
human race destroys itself the end
that's that's how the world's gon to end
I don't think he's all gung-ho about it
like he used to be I know well like I
said he gets the nice end of it he
doesn't get the [__] end the sck like
most of the people in that [__] cult
do like you know works for him yeah 99%
of the other people in that [__] it
doesn't work for they're like hey we're
just going to take all your money and
treat you like [__] and put you up
somewhere with no toilet paper bye you
know what I mean it's that kind of how
many more torture devices do we have uh
that's it that the last one that was the
braen bow was the last one wa you you
want to think you could can you think of
some more no that's it okay that's all I
can think of I mean we've been on for
almost four hours [__] it's a long ass
show see you were having a good time
yeah yeah I knew this was going to be a
fun show though it's only 11 I mean as
[__] up as it is okay um but at least
it was a long time ago all these poor
people [__] suffering although okay
so now that we've talked about all the
torture devices what out of all the
torture devices that we've talked about
if you had to CH if they said okay we're
just going to kill you right now um or
we're going to tort you even worse
unless you pick one of these yeah what
one would you pick the
rack you'd still pick the rack yeah yeah
not with the fire
option reg rack just a regular rack yeah
now let me let me think which one would
I want now I'm not counting like
um I don't know I don't want to say I
don't want to count the thumb screws or
the the scold Bridal or anything like
that because yeah I I would say yeah
probably like the scold Bridal because
that doesn't kill you at least but it's
like still yeah that wasn't a death
thing that was just a hum
um okay I
don't I'm going to say maybe maybe out
of all of
these
jeez I'm going to go with scavenger's
daughter which one was it oh that was
that was the one with the that killed
you though eventually eventually but the
rap does too yeah so I thought you could
survive the rack yeah you can well you
could survive the scavenger's daughter
too okay but I'm just saying the rack is
kind of like the opposite of the
Scavengers scavenger start kind of like
squishes you together like makes you
into a little like ball or whatever okay
but I don't know yeah maybe the rack
would be better but I I don't really
know man I don't know all of these are
bad just dislocation the Vol joint like
all the ones I talked about I don't I
don't really know I mean maybe the one
that just squished your foot but still
or squished your hand but
still I mean I guess that's kind of the
whole point of it is none of them are
supposed to be super playing right Danny
saying if [__] sees me being tortured
like James Bond of the [__] C Royale
he's hting
bow oh and he's laugh what you laugh for
I'm laughing you died [__] scratching
my balls [__] just [__] oh my God
that was so funny yeah I'm gonna say
though like this might be TMI but you
love having your dick smacked yeah yeah
smack that [__]
shirt hit it
again not super hard but you know what I
mean yeah yeah he does like that yeah it
knocks all the blood to the end of it
right right right yeah you get nasty
on yeah well I'm just saying we're
talking about torture so I'm just saying
this not torture though I [__] like
it yeah he
does Jenny [__] slap that
[__] do it again yeah he's like hold
hold it tight at the base and that's
back
it that's [__]
funny Jenny giv up all my secrets you
love that sh my secret moves you love
that
[__] [__] oh you come on you love it
trying to get laid you talking about J
trying to get laid oh I know I'm going
to get okay all right if not tonight
then tomorrow morning okay so you know
what I mean yeah I'm kind of drug right
now well yeah me too but you know what I
mean weapons and stuff hey where have
you been hello sadly only just got the
notification oh my God we've been on for
almost four hours
damn four hours of we're already talking
about slapping dicks and sticking pears
up your asses yeah open it up [__]
All Med how's your channel been weapons
and stuff yeah holy I haven't seen you
post in a while yeah we haven't seen you
in a while yeah where have you been yeah
if you guys don't know weapons and stuff
is a British um [__] Channel and uh he
uh he he's big into like gas masks and
paramilitary stuff like [__] the [__]
everything like the chemical detectors
[__] uh [__] radiation detectors
uh he's got uh some pretty interesting
[__] deactivated submachine guns and
weapons that he has and uh which is you
know that's basically all you can have
in England weapons you need to come to
[__] United States man come to
Florida you get the real [__] thing
here you'd love it we'll go shooting I
got to range [__] 15 minutes from
here take J
he yeah cuz we kind of live in a rural
sort of area well kind of sort of kind
of so there's like a lot of shooting
room there's all kinds of shooting stuff
around here [__] they shooting the
neighborhood they hear [__] yeah you
can hear it sometimes [__] zero I'm
not sure where it is exactly just hear
him zero in AR15 well like I said if you
have an acre or more you can shoot you
can shoot on your own property I'm at
0.9 Acres I we have like slightly less
than an acre but yeah so we're not
allowed yeah they did that on purpose I
think well and there's I wouldn't sh
there's houses like you got to make a
back stop right that's what I mean there
I mean we have almost an acre but
there's houses all around here yeah
Mississippi is shooting the house but
only pistols but I had a snail trap to
catch the bullets yeah cuz I shoot 9 mm
in house shoot holes in the walls yeah
you don't shoot yeah cuz you know shoot
9 mm right in the house fix [__] zero
and [__] making sure loads work good and
[__] because hand loading ammo yeah all
right but you can't shoot high power
rifle in the house it's too [__] loud
cats would go crazy please don't do that
no I wouldn't do it oh my God the cats
would flip out I would flip out I'm like
oh my God what's all that [__] noise
you already blare the TV louder enough I
don't really need like [__] all that
noise on top of it said the new YouTube
notifications are awful yeah that's I
mean yeah a lot of people have said that
but yeah we've went on for almost four
hours but yeah this was like a super fun
show I thought it would be even though
it's a it's a terrible Grim I haven't
been getting notifications on any of
your channel updates either we oh Danny
ring said um where's that raccoon
commercial uh she got uh wait a minute
where is it it's in there somewhere it's
it's h I just thought I saw where is
that raccoon there it
was just to make you happy I already put
that there all right so man we got to go
to bed it's almost 11:30 yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed you guys seem
to enjoy this medieval torture thing
like I said it's [__] up but at least
it was a long time ago so I don't feel
too bad like making all these [__]
jokes about it but uh yeah so we will be
back on Friday night for the Sidetrack
show uh we will be doing a pregame
because we're going to momenta Mory yeah
club night uh so it'll be a club night
so we're going to do like a pregame
Friday the 13th it's Friday the 13th
yeah Jen will probably be decked out too
you're going to be one of your sexy new
outfits probably oh I'm going to be a
sexy new outfit we'll see I don't know
what I'm do my hair yet I got to color
my hair and cut it and [__] like that
tomorrow too so uh but yeah I already
know what dress I'm going to wear and
all that kind of stuff it'll be cool but
yeah so we'll see you guys again yeah
we'll see you guys again on uh Friday
night for the Sidetrack show so
hopefully you guys can join us for that
thank you for dropping by this evening
and having a conversation with us about
the torture [__] uh thank you for super
chats and we will see you guys again on
Friday good